Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel. Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel. Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Malen nach Zahlen im Radio jeden letzten Donnerstag hier auf Fritz. Das Chaos Radio, der Blue Moon, der komplett geändert wird vom Chaos Computer Club, wo es dann um Themen geht, wo, na wie kann man sagen, Nerds, Hacker, mal die Welt erklären. Zu Gast sind heute vom CCC Constanze Kurz. Hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und Dodger. Und wir sind heute hier zusammengekommen, weil Hacker haben ja normalerweise damit zu tun, mit Computern oder Technik im weitesten Sinne oder wenigstens irgendwie Bastelei. Es gibt aber auch manchmal Lebensbereiche in der Welt, wo sich die Hacker dann irgendwann sagen, so Leute, das geht so nicht weiter. Wir müssen uns mal drum kümmern. Und genau um so ein Thema geht es heute. Ja, ich wünsche, ich würde jetzt die Leute, die Gesichter der Leute sehen, die vorm Radio sitzen, nein, das Chaos-Radio zum Fußball, die Welt geht unter...
Wir waren das nicht, das war Markus ganz allein.
Nein, nein, Entschuldigung. In der Sendungsvorbereitung hat ein Herr, dem ihr unter NBLR auf Twitter folgen könnt, gesagt, müsste man heute nicht eigentlich auch mal, weil Hacker ja auch und Fußball und überhaupt, wir sind wedeln, dass wir uns den Themenwünschen der verehrten Hackergemeinde verwehren. Nibler ist schuld. Genau, bei ihm könnt ihr euch beschweren, wenn euch das nicht passt. Und wir kommen jetzt zum eigentlichen Thema, Politik. Was tatsächlich aber auch nicht so weit weg davon ist, weil es ja lange Zeit relativ klare Grenzen gab. Also auf der einen Seite sind die Leute, die sich irgendwie so mit diesem komischen Internet, von dem immer alle reden, dass es sich aber nie durchsetzen wird, beschäftigen. Auf der anderen Seite sind die Politiker, die das alles ganz schlimm finden und am liebsten verbieten und regulieren wollen. Und dann begab es sich aber, dass doch so, naja, sich das vermischt hat. Das fing an mit Demonstrationen, Vorratsdatenspeicherungen, dürfte jeder von euch schon mal gehört haben, wo zum ersten Mal, also in meiner Meinung zumindest ein technisches Thema für so viel Aufriss gesorgt hat, dass Leute da echt auf die Straße gegangen sind in der Anzahl, die auch fünfstellig war. Und jetzt gibt es aktuell etwas, was für mich zumindest auch so eine Neuheit ist eher. Es gibt ein Gesetz, das mit Hackerhilfe durchgesetzt wurde, muss man so kurz sagen. Dabei handelt es sich um das Transparenzgesetz in Hamburg. Deswegen ist Dodger auch hier. Dodger kommt vom Chaos Computer Club Hamburg. Und damit wir ganz von vorn anfangen, auch wirklich alle mitkriegen, worum es ja eigentlich geht, was genau ist ein Transparenzgesetz?
Naja, im Grunde genommen das, was der Name schon sagt, nämlich ein Gesetz, das die Verwaltung dazu zwingt, alles, was sie an Informationen hat, offen zu legen. Und zwar proaktiv. Das ist der Kern.
Das heißt, die Verwaltung muss jetzt irgendwie jeden einzelnen Handschlag, den sie tut. Frau Kasubke hat eine Packung Barocklammern aus dem Lager geholt. Nein, wahrscheinlich nicht, aber worum geht es?
Nämlich relativgehend, genau. Es geht primär darum, dass alle Verträge, Dienstanweisungen unter bestimmten Umständen, alles, was die Stadt im fürsorglichen Handeln für das Volk tut, auch veröffentlicht werden muss. Das heißt, wenn Schlaglöcher repariert werden, wenn große Bauvorhaben anstehen, wenn irgendwelche Beschaffungsgeschichten passieren über einer bestimmten Schwelle, dann muss das veröffentlicht werden.
Okay, veröffentlicht in einer bestimmten Form oder einfach, dass man sagt, Hauptsache, wir haben da drauf Zugriff und dann kriegen wir irgendwie Word-Dokumente ausgedruckt an die Stadtafel gehängt?
Genau, gescannte PDFs, die dann wieder ausgedruckt werden. Da kommt der Hacker ins Spiel und zwar haben wir da relativ klar reingeschrieben, dass wir ein Informationsregister im Internet kriegen, in das dann die Dokumente Maschinenlesbar, Forderung des CCC seit 1984, der Maschinenlesbare Staat, eingestellt werden und dann auch entsprechend weiterverarbeitet werden können.
Es ist eigentlich ein bisschen Paradigmenwechsel. Wir haben natürlich heute schon im Bund ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und in einigen Ländern. Aber in der Regel ist da der Unterschied sozusagen Push und Pull nenn ich es jetzt mal. Also man wendet sich entweder hin an den Staat und kann dann vielleicht Informationen bekommen oder aber der Staat wird wie jetzt in Hamburg selbst aktiv und gibt sich erst mal von vornherein transparent. Das ist glaube ich auch der große Unterschied und wir hoffen natürlich sehr, dass das Schule machen wird und Hamburg dann nicht alleine sein wird. Und ich darf schon mal sagen, wir hören aus anderen Ländern Interesse, Bundesländern. Also das ist insgesamt sehr positiv aufgenommen worden, auch weil da noch ein politischer Hack dabei ist. Nämlich ja letztlich sich alle Parteien in Hamburg darauf geeinigt haben. Das ist natürlich ein großer Erfolg, denn alle Parteien können letztlich auch sagen, hey war unser Erfolg.
Aber gut, vielleicht können wir das tatsächlich, weil das soll ja heute darum gehen, Hacker machen Politik, also mischen bei der Politik mit auf eine Art und Weise, die tatsächlich auch konstruktive Auswirkungen hat. Ich würde gerne diese Geschichte, bevor wir sagen über das Thema, vielleicht auch in abstrakter und Metaebenen reden, einfach mal von vorne anfangen. Also wir haben die Situation, Hamburg vor zwei Jahren oder so oder vor einem Jahr?
Ja, schön wäre es gewesen. Also vor ziemlich genau zehn Monaten.
Okay, das ging schnell. Okay, Hamburg vor zehn Monaten. Es gibt ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, das heißt theoretisch kann ich hingehen und sagen, du Staat gib mal bitte und dann kann der Staat immer noch sagen, Geheimnis und so können wir leider nicht machen. Ich sage Wasserverträge in Berlin, ein ganz lokales Beispiel und dann sind also Leute auf die Idee gekommen, es wäre doch geil diese Daten zu fordern. Jetzt ist es ja so, du hast gerade gesagt, Chaos Computer Club fordert das ja irgendwie, das Schlagwort ist private Daten schützen, öffentliche Daten nutzen, fordert das schon immer. Wie ist es aber jetzt gekommen, dass vor zehn Monaten jemand aus dem Club auch gesagt hat, ich mache jetzt Politik?
Na ja, da sind wir so ein bisschen dazu gekommen wie die Jungfrau zum Kind und zwar gibt es diesen vor allem mehr Demokratie, den gibt es bundesweit und die setzen sich seit Jahrzehnten für direkte Demokratie ein und für Bürgerbeteiligung und die sind mit genau diesem Satz auf uns zugekommen und zwar haben die sich vor, ja im Juli letzten Jahres zusammengesetzt mit Transparency International und den Piraten zum Teil auch und haben gesagt, wir wollen jetzt hier als wichtige Säule der Demokratie, wollen wir jetzt auch die Informationen haben, die wir brauchen, um als Bürger mitwirken zu können und die kamen dann auch mit diesem berühmten Satz nach dem Maschinenlesbaren Staat und private Daten schützen, öffentliche Daten nutzen, direkt auf uns zu und haben gesagt, naja, da müsst ihr ja eigentlich mitmachen und da waren wir dann so ein bisschen verhaftet.
Es ist natürlich auch immer schön, wenn man eine gute Mischung von Organisationen hat, weil verschiedene Kompetenzen zusammenwirken können und weil man natürlich letztlich auch die Anzahl der Menschen, die sich dann engagiert, vergrößert und auch die Medien Schlagkraft und die Durchsetzung Schlagkraft damit.
Na ja, vor allen Dingen auch die verschiedenen Erfahrungen, also mehr Demokratie ist ein Verein, der seit Jahren oder seit Jahrzehnten sogar sehr viele Erfahrungen in Kampagnen hat, auf der Straße, Unterschriften sammeln, Offline-Campagning, Leute ansprechen, was ja jetzt nicht so das Kernggebiet des gewöhnlichen Hackers ist.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, der Unterschied ist ja schon relativ groß, weil der Klischeehacker, den man sich vorstellt und da steckt ja ein Kern Wahrheit drin ist, der hat gerne ein genau spezifiziertes Problem, das er so lange auseinander nimmt, bis es gelöst ist und dann kommt das nächste. Und das ist ja, könnte ich mir jetzt vorstellen, auch eher diffus. Wie war denn das für dich persönlich? Bist du jetzt sozusagen, also war das auch so ein Ding, irgendwie, okay, die Leute kommen zum Club und sagen, ihr müsstet jetzt mal und dann, wer nicht schnell genug einen Schritt nach hinten gemacht hat, ist der Freiwillige oder wie liegt das?
Ja, so ähnlich. Also es gibt ja im Clubumfeld Leute, die sich mehr mit löten, programmieren, Technik beschäftigen und es gibt natürlich auch Leute, die sich mehr mit Politik beschäftigen. Und da war das dann eher so dieses Ding, ja, da kommt so eine Mail von denen an die allgemeine E-Mail-Adresse, können da mal die Politik-Nerds hingehen. Und dann haben wir uns gedacht, naja, die planen da so ein Informationsregister, helfen wir denen so ein bisschen, wie man das technisch ausgestalten kann. Das war so die erste Idee. Und damit bin ich auf dem Camp dann irgendwann aufgeschlagen und habe gesagt, so hier, die planen das. Und dann sagten dann die Leute, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, ja, macht mal mit. Und dann kamen die mir mit der Idee, wir brauchen jetzt von jeder Organisation eine Vertrauensperson. Und wir brauchen jetzt dann demnächst mal eine Unterschriftensammlung. Und da brauchen wir in drei Monaten 15.000 Unterschriften. Lass mal sammeln gehen. Und plötzlich hingen wir da dann drin, diese zwei, drei Leute von uns, die sich das erstmal nur angucken wollten und hatten dann da irgendwie ein 18-seitiges Gesetz geschrieben und haben uns plötzlich mit Paragrafen beschäftigt, wo wir vorher nie drauf gekommen wären und haben solche Echtweltprobleme lösen müssen.
Wie hat sich das vom Programmieren unterscheiden, so ein Gesetzestext zu schreiben? Wenn du ein Programm hast, ist es theoretisch eine mathematisch perfekte Lösung, die möglichst schmal ist, aber das Problem korrekt und immer löst und nicht abstürzt dabei. Beim Gesetzestext muss man dann auch Rücksicht nehmen auf andere Leute. Möglicherweise sind sich sogar alle Leute in der Vereinigung, die da kämpfen, nicht einig. Wie ist das so ein Gesetz zu schreiben? Wie macht man das überhaupt?
Das Lustige ist, dass selbst da in diesen Kreisen wie diesen Bürgervereinen mittlerweile so Sachen wie Wikis angekommen sind. Das heißt, wir haben das Gesetz vom ersten Wort an komplett öffentlich in einem Wiki entwickelt. Dadurch hast du natürlich eine sehr gute Möglichkeit, das auszuarbeiten und dadurch zu schauen und Formulierungen zu klären. Wir sind aber auch gar nicht von Anfang an rangegangen und haben gesagt, wir schreiben jetzt einen juristischen Text, sondern wir schreiben auf, was wir wollen, was wir da drin haben wollen. Als wir dann so halbwegs fertig waren und gesagt haben, so wollen wir das, sind wir dann zu einem Juristen gegangen, in dem Fall einem Bundesverfassungsrichter AD, und haben gesagt, hier guck dir das mal an, dann hat er gesagt, ja ist gut, das schmeißen wir weg, das schreiben wir jetzt nochmal auf Juristendeutsch neu. Und dann ist es halt dann eingemacht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Vorarbeit war aber nicht ganz umsonst, einfach nur ein Gesetzestext, aber die Ideen konnten schon transportiert werden.
Genau, inhaltlich ist es halt immer noch unser Gesetz. Nur das Problem bei Gesetzen ist, die werden nicht für Bürger geschrieben, sondern von Juristen für Juristen. Und damit ein Jurist dich ernst nimmt, wenn du so ein Gesetz schreibst, dann muss das halt auch in einer Sprache sein, die er versteht.
Dann sollte das auch nicht zu komisch sein. Letztlich gibt es definierte Begriffe. Die sind also juristische Termini. Hinter denen ja oft lange Kommentierungen und welche Entscheidungen stehen. Man muss die kennen und denke, man muss natürlich auch ein paar Fallstrecken beachten, nämlich dass man auch Sachen nicht weglassen kann, die man regeln muss. Insofern war eh klar, dass Juristen drüber gucken müssen. Man kann sich den ganzen Prozess in diesem Wiki auch ansehen, wenn man will. Also das ist ja auch transparent in dem so, dass man nachvollziehen kann, was sich verändert hat.
Genau, du hast dann teilweise, wo unser einer sagt, ja da kommt jetzt rein, alle Informationen sollen veröffentlicht werden. Und dann kommt ein Jurist und erklärt dir, dass sollen, müssen, können, dürfen ganz klar juristisch definierte Begriffe sind. Und du musst erstmal lernen, das überhaupt juristisch auszudrücken, was du eigentlich meinst.
Na ja und dazu kommt natürlich noch, dass es für eine Kampagne eine sinnvolle Sache ist, einen honorigen Juristenintim zu haben. Wir wollen mal nicht, also, es war schon klar, dass wir Erfolg haben wollten mit der Sache, wie man eigentlich immer bei Kampagnen will. Und insofern ist natürlich auch ein bisschen strategisches Denken immer dabei.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen, dass sozusagen, also ihr seid jetzt nicht die ersten Leute gewesen, die sich irgendwo hinsetzen, ein Wiki aufmachen und dort Sachen reinschreiben, die sie gerne in der Welt wollen. Wie war denn, wie ist es denn passiert, dass es von dieser Idee dazu kam, dass es tatsächlich in der Öffentlichkeit wahrgenommen wird?
Na ja, du hast in Hamburg als einziges Bundesland einen verbindlichen Volksentscheid. Das heißt, wenn du die nötigen Hürden überwindest, drei Stück, dann kannst du schon mal so viel Öffentlichkeit erzeugen, schon nach der ersten Hürde, die wir sehr leicht geschafft haben, mit diesen 15.000 Unterschriften, dass sich der Senat damit beschäftigen muss und die Regierung. Und dann bist du auch schon mal in der Öffentlichkeit. Und allein durch diese Tatsache, dass wir innerhalb von sechs Wochen diese 15.000 Unterschriften gesammelt haben, haben wir faktisch mit mehr als 15.000 Menschen gesprochen und ihnen das erklärt. Und dadurch trägst du das halt weiter, diese Idee.
Man muss vielleicht auch noch mal dazusehen, mehr Demokratie hat viel Erfahrung damit und waren ja auch schon erfolgreich in früheren Projekten. Ist auch nicht ganz zufällig, dass natürlich Hamburg ausgewählt wurde, weil es eben für diese Form von Volksentscheiden besonders angenehmes Pflaster ist, denn der Senat ist da ja rechtlich auch schon gebunden. Das heißt, nicht zusammenzutun mit anderen Nerds, die Erfahrung haben mit solchen Dingen, ist immer von Vorteil.
Also um das nochmal ganz deutlich zu machen, dieses Konstrukt Volksentscheid gibt es schon anderswo in Deutschland auch, aber wenn es sozusagen für den Willen des Antragstellers positiv ausgeht, heißt das in den meisten Ländern nur, da müsste mal jemand, könnte da nicht mal jemand und in Hamburg ist es also so, wenn ein Volksentscheid im Sinne des Antrags entschieden wird, dann ist ja quasi das Gesetz sprucht.
Richtig, also in Hamburg sieht es so aus, du brauchst erstmal 10.000 gültige Unterschriften, sprich 15.000 wegen Puffer, dann muss sich der Senat und die Bürgerschaft damit beschäftigen mit deinem Anliegen, dann können sie es annehmen oder sie können es ignorieren, dann kommt die zweite Stufe, das ist dann das Volksbegehren, da musst du fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung unterschreiben lassen, der wahlfähigen Bevölkerung, das heißt in Hamburg circa 62.000.
Das ist also schon kein Pappenstil.
Und die hätten wir in drei Wochen sammeln müssen, also in einem Zeitraum von drei Wochen. Und wenn du die wiederum beisammen hast, wären wir bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl 2013 auf dem Wahlzettel gewesen und dann brauchst du eine 50 Prozent Mehrheit der Wähler. Und dann ist das Gesetz, dann ist das, was du geschrieben hast, durch.
Und zwar ist die Hürde hoch und das ist auch glaube ich von Anfang an klar gewesen. Insofern war natürlich auch immer das Ziel, mit der Politik da ins Gespräch zu kommen. Denn man kann natürlich auch drohen, quasi mit der Möglichkeit, die Bürger das durchdrücken zu lassen durch ihre Stimme. Aber man kann natürlich auch ein bisschen in Kooperation hoffen. Gerade weil eben diese Beteiligungsgesetz in Hamburg, also Bürgerbegehren, doch ein relativ starkes Mittel ist.
Das heißt also man stellt sich hin und sagt, so pass mal auf Leute, wir haben ja diesen Gesetzestext geschrieben. Wenn der 2013 gewählt wird, dann kommt er genau so rein. Oder er setzt uns jetzt mit uns an den Tisch und dann könnte er möglicherweise noch mal einen kleinen Kompromiss aushandeln.
Ja, beziehungsweise führt es bei uns den Weg einfach dahin, dass wir am 28. Februar eine Anhörung hatten vor dem Justizausschuss.
Also das war, bevor wir zur Anhörung kommen, ich wollte gerade sagen nach der Sammlung. Wie war diese Sammlung? Also sagen, bist du da tatsächlich persönlich losgegangen, raus auf die Straße, wie man das so kennt?
Ja, und zwar in der herrlichen Zeit von Anfang November bis Mitte Dezember.
Okay, du hast wirklich alles gegeben, oder?
Vor allen Dingen, wenn man das Hamburger Wetter kennt. In Hamburg unterscheidet sich ja Sommer und Winter durch die Temperatur des Regens. Und gerade so auf Weihnachtsmärkten stehen und dann den Leuten, die gerade beim 4. Glühwein sind, erklären, was man da gerade politisch macht und dass sie da vielleicht für unterschreiben sollen, dass es eine gute Sache ist, war schon Sport.
Man lernt da was. Soziale Fähigkeiten für Hacker sind auch wichtig.
Ja, das war total dufte.
Sollte man die vorher haben oder kann man die dann währenddessen lernen?
Oh, nee, man kann die auch währenddessen lernen. Also es waren auch einige Leute aus dem Hamburger Club mit, die noch nie solche Dinge gemacht haben.
Also mit Menschen interagieren?
Nein, Unterschriften sammeln. Die Hamburger Hacker interagieren ständig. Nein, aber die halt zum ersten Mal auf der Straße standen und man muss sich ja auch überwinden. Du sprichst jemanden an, entschuldigen Sie, ich habe hier ein Anliegen, würden Sie bitte unterschreiben? Und dann sammelst du am ersten Tag vielleicht zehn Unterschriften und bist so total glücklich und dann stolperst du über jemanden, der irgendeiner Partei angehört, die gewohnt ist, Unterschriften zu sammeln und der hat dann 100 in derselben Zeit. Am nächsten Tag reifst du dich drauf zusammen und hast dann vielleicht schon 30 und so weiter und so fort. Also man lernt das. Das ist halt ein Überwindungsprozess, aber es ist ja vieles im Leben.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die meisten von uns ja auch nur die andere Seite kennen. Du gelerfst dich trasselang und dann sagt irgendjemand so ein komischer Typ in Willen. Nee, nee, nee, danke. So ist das da. Konntest du mit den Leuten tatsächlich über das Thema reden oder war es eher so, ja ich gebe dir meine Unterschrift und dann ist gut?
Nee, das war uns auch wichtig. Also gerade während dieser ersten Phase, wenn du da halt rausgehst und die Leute erstmal damit bekannt machen musst, dann willst du die halt auch aufklären. Also dann kommen auch schon mal zehn Minuten Gespräche zustande oder Leute, die komplett sagen, nee, leh nicht ab und wir können da sowieso nichts machen. Oder häufigster Satz, den du hörst, ist die Politiker machen doch eh was sie wollen. Und da muss man dann halt wirklich sein Demokratieverständnis haben und muss halt mit den Leuten auch argumentieren und auch mit den Leuten reden. Und da haben wir uns auch wirklich die Zeit für genommen.
Das finde ich dann jetzt eine gute Überleitung zu dieser Anhörung, sozusagen die Politiker machen noch eh doch. Weil das ist ja auch etwas, was viele Leute befürchten, warum sie sich selber nicht engagieren. Die hatten dann also diese Unterschriften zusammen, das waren genug, seit sie zu dieser Anhörung gekommen sind. Hast du vorher schon mal mit Politikern geredet? Also jetzt sozusagen in so einem offiziellen Rahmen?
Diese komische Spezies, die immer in den Zoos gehalten wird.
Du lachst, aber tatsächlich ist es für viele Leute draußen, weil es viel von den Politikern passiert. Und die haben keinen Umgang damit. Und es macht manche auch den Eindruck, da ist irgendwo oben in einem Wolkenschloss sitzen. Also Leute, die entscheiden so Dinge. Und da kommt man manchmal vielleicht ran, aber eigentlich eher auch nicht.
Na gut, also ich persönlich hatte schon vorher mal Kontakt mit dieser Spezies, weil ich auch im Anti-Aktabereich tätig war.
Oder auch bei der Wahlstift, da gab es auch mal den Ärger mit dem Hamburger Wahlstift. Da war der CCC Hamburg natürlich auch aktiv.
Genau, auch über Open Data und so weiter. Also man hat immer schon mal mit denen zu tun. Großer Vorteil an einem Stadtstaat wie Hamburg ist natürlich, die können nicht so weit weglaufen. Also die rennen da überall rum.
Nur noch mehr. Es ist eigentlich auch kleiner. Das ganze Abgeordnetenhaus ist ja vergleichsweise klein. Es ist familiärer und auch weniger aggressiv. Der Umgangston ist immer noch regelfreundlicher, als man es im Bund kennt. Es gibt weniger Mediendruck. Das ist auch wichtig, denke ich. Man kommt da eher noch Bürger und sozusagen Regierende ins Gespräch.
Also das ist ganz wichtig. Du triffst da auch durchaus mal den Abgeordneten abends beim Bier zufällig in der Kneipe. Weil das ist halt auch ein Teilzeitparlament, ähnlich wie in Berlin. Und dadurch halt auch einfach das ganz normale Leute sind, die ganz normalen Berufen nachgehen.
Keine Berufspolitiker, zumindest nicht alle.
Trotzdem gab es dann sozusagen einen offiziellen Termin. War das dann aufregend, also da so darzutreten?
Na gut, wenn du halt so ein freundliches Schreiben kriegst mit dem Stadtwappen drauf. Und da steht dann drauf, wir laden sie freundlich ein zur Anhörung vor dem Justizausschuss. Lustigerweise war bei dieser Anhörung im Rathaus alles voll. Und sie haben das dann in ein recht teures Hotel in der Nachbarschaft verlagern müssen, was die Bürgerschaftsverwaltung schon wieder ganz besonders genervt hat, weil es natürlich Geld kostet. Aber es waren über 100 Zuschauer da bei der ganzen Veranstaltung, die fünf Stunden gedauert hat. Und klar bist du da erstmal aufgeregt und sitzt da diesen ganzen Leuten gegenüber, die du sonst mehr oder weniger aus der Presse kennst. Das war aber schon für uns das erste Zeichen, das war eine wahnsinnig konstruktive Sitzung. Also das haben uns auch hinterher die Leute bestätigt, die öfters bei so was sind. Die haben gesagt, sie hätten noch nie eine so konstruktive Sitzung erlebt. Da gibt es 70 Seiten Wortprotokoll dazu auf Papier. Das Ganze durfte nicht gestreamt werden aus irgendeinem Grund.
Ja, es gab auch ein Twitter-Verbot, hat sich aber keiner dran gehalten.
Genau, also das war halt einfach so ein Punkt. Und da laden die dann halt wirklich, jede Partei lädt einen Experten ein, oder mehrere, die sich vorher extrem mit der Materie beschäftigen. Und da hatten wir dann plötzlich fünf oder sechs Juraprofessoren sitzen, die alle Lehrstühle hinhaben. Und das war also eine juristische Fachberatung, die du nicht hättest bezahlen können. Und die war kostenlos. Und die haben uns genau die Punkte rausgepickt, wo sie gesagt haben, da gibt es unter Umständen verfassungsrechtliche Probleme, da greift ihr in ein höherrangiges Recht ein, du kannst auf Landesebene halt nicht im Bundesrecht eingreifen und so weiter und so fort. Der Datenschutzbeauftragte, Professor Kaspar, schönen Gruß, war immer ein sehr großer Freund, der hat sich so oft mit uns zusammengesetzt, er hat in seiner Behörde die Mitarbeiter des Gesetzes lesen lassen und wieder und wieder und wieder. Das war sehr, sehr konstruktiv, da ist viel rübergekommen bei.
Okay, also wirklich, also fünf Besitzungen in der Öffentlichkeit, wo aber tatsächlich übers Thema geredet wurde und wo nicht das passiert ist, wo ich mich persönlich fürchten würde, ist sozusagen, da kommt irgendein Experte an und fährt er sozusagen einfach, weil er das ganze Geschäft gewöhnt ist, so über das Maul, dass du denkst, huch, was ist denn hier gerade passiert? Also das wurde tatsächlich übers Thema geredet und pro und contra und zwar nicht, wie man das so klischeehaft kennt, so Sticheleien, ein intrigantes.
Ja, es gab da wohl Befindlichkeiten von einem der Experten gegenüber mehr Demokratie, aber aus einer anderen Kampagne. Der war dann schon teilweise sehr polemisch. Aber wenn einer von sechs irgendwie zetert und die anderen fünf irgendwo sinnvoll konstruktiv daran arbeiten wollen, dann merkt man das halt auch sehr schnell, dass das ein Troll ist.
Okay, also und schon da war aber klar, dass keine Partei generell abgab abgeneigt ist?
Nein, das ist halt immer die Schwierigkeit. Diese Leute, die in den Ausschüssen sitzen, sind natürlich Abgeordnet von ihrer Partei dafür, vertreten aber ja nie die gesamte Parteimeinung. Und das war halt quasi so eine, wir verschaffen uns mal einen Überblick, was da überhaupt läuft. Da aber ja zwei der Parteien, die in Hamburg in der Bürgerschaft sitzen, schon im Bündnis waren, es war ja ein breites Bündnis, also die Linke und die Grünen waren von vornherein dabei, hattest du natürlich schon mal zwei von fünf Parteien mit im Boot. Und dadurch konnte man natürlich auch viel besser arbeiten.
Okay, gute Voraussetzungen. Und dann wäre der nächste Schritt eigentlich gewesen, dann innerhalb von drei Wochen, wie viel waren es 62.000?
Ja, 62.000 gültig. Also wir haben uns so auf 70.000 bis 75.000 Unterschriften eingestellt.
Aber bevor das passieren konnte, ist was anderes passiert?
Ja, bevor das passieren konnte, bekamen wir dann eine Mail, respektive einen Anruf von dem Fraktionsvorsitzenden der SPD, die in Hamburg allein regiert. Und der sagte so was wie, lasst uns mal treffen.
Wir müssen reden. War das eine offizielle Anfrage oder war das eher so ein unter der Hand, lasst mal, also sag das mal bitte noch keinem und wir treffen uns mal, dann schnacken wir mal kurz.
Na, das war halt schon im Rahmen dieser normalen Volksgesetzgebung, hat die Bürgerschaft in der Senat ja die Möglichkeit, Gespräche aufzunehmen. Und das haben sie halt damit auch getan. Und da die SPD allein regierend ist, konnten die das natürlich auch alleine erst mal initiieren.
Also schon eine hochoffizielle Anfrage.
Ja, das war eine offizielle E-Mail.
Genau, okay. Gut, dann werden wir uns erstmal beschäftigen, was da passiert ist auf diesem zweiten hochoffiziösen Termin. Bevor wir das machen, gibt es aber erst mal das Fritz-Info-Nachrichtenwetter und Verkehr, wo ihr auch gleich noch wahrscheinlich erfahren werdet, dass es immer noch nur zu zwei im EM-Spiel steht. Heute, wie immer am letzten Donnerstag im Monat aus der Dezember das Chaosradio in Blue Moon auf Fritz. Zu Gast sind Dodger, hallo und guten Abend zurück.
Moin.
Und Constanze Kurz. Beides sind Hacker, die es gewagt, versucht, was auch immer haben, Politik zu machen, statt nur am Rechner abzuhängen. Und im speziellen Fall berichten wir heute drüber, weil das Transparenzgesetz in Hamburg angenommen wurde. Und das wurde tatsächlich unter anderem mit der Mithilfe von Hackern verwirklicht. Wir erzählen jetzt am Anfang der Sendung noch die Geschichte. Wenn ihr währenddessen immer mal wieder Fragen habt oder möglicherweise, wenn wir damit durch sind, selber, was zur Politik als technisch interessierter Mensch, sage ich mal, sagen möchte, könnt ihr gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Und wir waren beim Transparenzgesetz dastehen geblieben, dass es eine Idee war von verschiedenen Initiativen, die mittels einer, wie ist das Fachwort?
Volksbefragung, Volksentscheid? Ein Volksentscheid.
Ein Volksentscheid eine erste Hürde genommen hatte. Und dann gab es eine öffentliche Anhörung vor dem Senat. Und dann sagte die SPD in Hamburg, sagt mal da hier Leute von dem Transparenzgesetz, das uns in Zukunft verpflichten soll, alle Entscheidungen, die wir treffen, öffentlich zu machen, so dass man sie auch Maschinen lesen kann, könnten wir uns mal treffen?
Genau, das war der Punkt, wo wir dann zu, naja, mehreren kleinen Keksen und Kaffee ins Rathaus gewandert sind. Gab keine Schnittchen, nur Kekse. Hamburg ist auch nicht so reich.
Shame. Wo sind sie, die Pfeffersäcke?
Genau, und dann haben wir halt, also um das noch vorweg zu schicken, wir haben nach der Anhörung im Justizausschuss, über die wir eben gesprochen haben, haben wir unseren Entwurf überarbeitet, haben das nochmal mit dem Datenschutz durchgekaut und haben dann einen überarbeiteten Entwurf eingereicht. Zeitlinie ist jetzt der 30. April. Da haben wir also dann nochmal das alles ausgemerzt, was an Kritik drin war und haben einen überarbeiteten Entwurf eingereicht und aufgrund dessen kam dann die Gesprächsanfrage.
Und dann seid ihr da zu Keksen hingegangen?
Genau, dann sind wir da hingegangen.
Wie viel wart ihr und wie viel waren die?
Ja, also du machst in so einer Volksinitiative sinnvoller Weise, dass du Vertrauenspersonen pro Organisation hast, das heißt in dem Fall waren wir zu dritt und haben dann halt im Endeffekt von unserer Seite noch jemanden mitgenommen, der juristisch bewanderter ist, sprich wir waren zu viert und auf deren Seite waren es auch immer so zwischen drei und fünf Personen.
Okay und was ist dann passiert?
Ja, dann sieht das halt so aus, dass die sagen, okay ihr macht den Eindruck, als wolltet ihr das wirklich durchdrücken, als meint ihr das ernst. Ihr habt im Winter so einen Haufen Unterschriften gesammelt, so ganz ohne Fleisch kann das nicht sein.
Da ist halt, Entschuldigung, ich muss in dieser Stelle kurz unterbrechen, das ist gerade tatsächlich noch ein Tor für die Deutschen gefallen. Möglicherweise schaffen die noch was, wir wissen es nicht genau. Egal, wollte ich nur angesagt haben, so.
Genau, wo waren wir? Ja, Tee und Kekse.
Ihr wolltet nur mal sagen, ich gucke nicht auf den Fernseher.
Na, ich auch nicht.
Ja, einer muss es ja machen, Entschuldigung.
Unser Moderator, der ist ja wirklich erstaunlich Fußball interessiert.
Ich bin multitaskingfähig im Gegensatz zu anderen Leuten hier. Du kannst mich auch immer daran erinnern, dass wir gerade dabei stehen geblieben waren, dass sich drei bis fünf Leute auf jeder Seite bei Keksen und Tee im Hamburger Senat über dieses Ding unterhalten haben und die Leute gesagt haben so, okay ihr scheint es ernst zu meinen, was machen wir jetzt?
Genau und dann kamen natürlich von denen auch wiederum Bedenken. Also das Hauptproblem ist ja, wir wollen ja die Verwaltung transparenter machen und keiner von uns hat jemals in der Verwaltung gearbeitet und von daher kennen wir die Abläufe da natürlich auch nicht so wirklich gut und dann waren da halt Leute, die auch in der Verwaltung arbeiten und die dann halt sagen konnten, so Freunde, wenn ihr das so macht, wie das da drin steht, dann legt ihr die Verwaltung lahm, weil dann sind die nur noch damit beschäftigt, Dokumente zu veröffentlichen.
Möglicherweise nicht die schlechteste, die aber gut.
Na gut, das ist natürlich jetzt auch einfach die Frage, möchte man den Vertrag über den Bau des Kindergartens in der Lessingstraße von vor 20 Jahren automatisch veröffentlicht haben oder interessieren sich dafür unter Umständen nur fünf Leute und die kriegen den ja eh auf Antrag? Und da musste man halt differenzieren. Dann gab es nochmal größere Diskussionen beim Thema Verträge, was so unser Hauptanliegen war, dass alle Verträge über 100.000 Euro veröffentlicht werden. Da sind wir leider nicht ganz hingekommen, weil da auch das BGB und die Vertragsfreiheit dahinter stehen und mussten daher dann, auf Deutsch gesagt, die Kröte schlucken und mussten sagen, okay, alles was der Daseinsvorsorge gilt, sprich Straßen, Verkehrswesen, medizinische Vorsorge, Schulen, Kultur, Sport, das haben wir alles mit reingebracht. Das muss zwingend veröffentlicht werden, alles andere soll veröffentlicht werden. Das ist wieder so eine geile juristische Formulierung.
Kannst du jetzt mit deiner Erfahrung erklären, was der Unterschied ist?
Ja, also müssen heißt sie müssen. Sie müssen auf jeden Fall. Soll heißt, eigentlich müssen sie, es sei denn es spricht was wichtiges dagegen und das können sie dann auch wirklich glaubhaft begründen. So das ist also die Definition von Sollbestimmung. Und da mussten wir leider ran, dass war auch der größte Einschnitt, der dann zu unserem Entwurf entstanden ist. Und dann ging es halt ewig lang geplänkelt hin und her. Es waren glaube ich insgesamt zehn Sitzungen, die teilweise bis nachts um zwei liefen. Und das wurde wirklich jedes Wort in jedem Paragraphen dreimal umgedreht. Und es kamen Gegenvorschläge. Dann ist das normale Verfahren so, wenn du ein Bündnis hast, das wir ja hatten, aus 15 oder 20 teilnehmenden Gruppen. Und die Regierung macht dann den Gegenvorschlag, wie die sich das Gesetz vorstellen. Diese Gegenvorschlag haben sie ja mit uns ausgehandelt im Endeffekt. Dann trägst du das halt zurück ins Bündnis, gehst da noch mal alle Punkte durch und sagst, kann jeder Bündnispartner dem zustimmen?
Verstehe.
Und als die dann gesagt haben, ja, wir können zustimmen, hat uns das Bündnis und diese drei Vertrauenspersonen dann halt damit beauftragt, okay, geht dahin und handelt diesen Kompromiss zu Ende aus.
Okay, ich muss noch einmal kurz unterbrechen, das ist auch noch das letzte Mal, das Halbfinale ist jetzt vorbei und Deutschland ist raus. Also 2-1 Endstand, Italien, Deutschland und können jetzt die Fahnen wieder einpacken. So, dann ist also diese unglaubliche, unglaubliche Sitzungsmarathon ist dann zu Ende gewesen und ihr hattet einen Kompromiss, mit dem zumindest die SPD-Lehrer leben konnten und die eigenen Leute. Wie ist das denn eigentlich innerhalb dieser Bewegung gewesen? Ist das da anstrengend? Also man hört das ja oft sagen, da kämpfen Leute für eine gute Sache, TM, und sind dann hauptsächlich damit beschäftigt, sich gegenseitig irgendwie um Details zu streiten.
Nee, das war eigentlich extrem konstruktiv. Weil das Grundanlegen halt klar war, dadurch, dass wir halt diesen Gesetzestext im letzten Jahr entwickelt haben, im Herbst, war eigentlich im Bündnis danach kein Grund mehr für irgendwelche Reibereien. Du hast halt vorher deine Punkte auf den Tisch gebracht, die du gerne rein haben wolltest, die die verschiedenen Gruppen drin haben wollten, das wurde diskutiert. Es gab zum Beispiel in einer Fassung als Beispiel mal die Forderung, alle Forschungsergebnisse auch offen zu legen, also der Open-Access-Ansatz. Da gab es dann natürlich größere Diskussionen im Bündnis dazu, weil es da auch durchaus Leute gibt, die andere Meinungen dazu haben und nicht solche radikalen Ansichten haben. Und dann ist das wie Basisdemokratie, es wird dann halt abgestimmt, wollen wir das weiter drin haben, wollen wir es nicht weiter drin haben, und dann gibt es einen Konsens.
Okay, also auch hier ein sehr schönes Positivbeispiel, dass sich der Leute dann auch in Konsens halten und dann nicht sagen, so alle allein machen wir das irgendwie so alleine. Bei diesen ewig langen Verhandlungen, wo um jedes einzelne Wort diskutiert wurde, hattest du den Eindruck, dass da die Politikseite das auch so ein bisschen als Test benutzt hat, also inwieweit und wie das man die Länge ziehen kann und dass sie auch noch das Gefühl haben, wir haben jetzt auch noch was gesagt oder war das wirklich alles, ging es da immer um die Sache?
Also so wie ich diese Verhandlungspartner und das war ja immer die gleiche Gruppe im Endeffekt, kennengelernt habe, ging es denen auch wirklich um die Sache. Also die haben eingesehen, dass dieses Informationsfreiheitsgesetz reformiert werden muss, waren glaube ich auch ein Stück weit froh, dass ihnen schon mal jemand die Kernarbeit abgenommen hat. Also wenn du so ein Gesetz von jetzt 20 Seiten parlamentarisch schreiben willst, dann sind da erst mal etliche Leute, die bezahlt werden müssen, ewige Monate damit beschäftigt, das geht durch X Gremien und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt hat ihnen halt jemand einen fertigen Entwurf auf den Tisch gelegt und sie konnten sagen, okay, können wir darüber nachdenken? Und das hat sich auch in den Gesprächen dann so rausgestellt, dass die also auch wirklich interessiert waren. Und also bestes Beispiel, ich habe da also wirklich von Fraktionsvorsitzenden oder juristisch, netzpolitischen Sprecher und Juristen aus der Fraktion nachts um vier E-Mails bekommen. Mir ist da noch was aufgefallen. Also die haben sich da wirklich mit befasst und haben daran gearbeitet.
Dann waren also, Frau Kurz verzieht die ganze Zeit das Gesicht, als ob sie entweder in Wiesn muss oder was wichtiges zu sagen hat.
Man muss sich schon klar machen, dass es eine sehr idealtypische Form von Bürgerbeteiligter Gesetzgebung ist, die mit dem normalen Gesetzgebungsprozess in den Ländern, aber vor allen Dingen im Bund nicht viel zu tun hat. Das ist natürlich schon so, dass der Gesetzgeber im Land und im Bund manchmal halbfertige oder ziemlich fertige Entwürfe vorliegen hat. Man muss sich überlegen, dass diese Form von Lobbyismus, die hier in diesem Fall positiv war, aber sonst ja auch gang und gäbe, es nichts Besonderes darstellt. Aber der Unterschied ist glaube ich, und warum es auch so konstruktiv geworden ist, dass ein transparenter Prozess war, sodass sie klar nicht hinter verschlossenen Türen darüber verhandelt haben, sondern dass dieser ganze Prozess so offen war. Und zum anderen war da auch der kleine Rangelein darüber, wer kann sich jetzt eigentlich den Haken machen. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig. Als dritte scheint mir sehr wichtig für diese extrem positive Beispiel, dass es in gewisser Weise dem Zeitgeist entspricht. Es ist klar geworden, dass das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in dem Bund und den Ländern eigentlich nicht so ganz die Erwartungen erfüllt hat. Und dass Transparenz und Beteiligung ohnehin auch wahrscheinlich auf Druck der Piraten hin gerade ein extrem wichtiges politisches Thema ist. Und dann wollte nur auch keine Partei von den drei, die nun mal dabei waren in der Bürgerschaft in Hamburg, irgendwie hinten anstehen. Das heißt, man sollte nicht denken, dass das der idealtypische Fall ist.
Okay, das ist ein positives Beispiel, aber es ist doch ein sehr positives Beispiel.
Ja, natürlich. Es ist ja auch schön, dass man so eine Erfahrung machen kann, weil man eben auch nicht immer nur gegen Betonwände und Betonköpfe läuft, sondern dass man das auch mal hinkriegen kann, irgendwie konstruktiv und miteinander.
Wir müssen mal eine kurze Wiederholung einflechten. Es gibt eine Chatsersendung auf freenote.org im Channel Chaosradio. Das hat den Unterschied zwischen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und Transparenzgesetz ganz kurz zusammengefasst. Informationsfreiheitsgesetz erlaubt dem Bürger hinzugehen, zu sagen, gib mal bitte die Informationen. Transparenzgesetz sagt, der Staat oder das Land in diesem Fall muss die Informationen von sich aus zur Verfügung stellen.
Im Grundsatz, genau.
In einer Form, die auch benutzbar ist. Also in diesem Fall maschinenlesbar. Es hört sich vorhin so an, als ob alle Parteien in Hamburg damit zugestimmt haben. Habt ihr nur die Grünen, die Linken und die SPD? Oder was haben die anderen da noch dazu gesagt?
Die Grünen, die Linken und die SPD, sondern die Grünen, die SPD und die CDU.
Das waren die Parteien, die heute schon in der Sendung aufgefallen sind. Davon rede ich.
Also, um das noch mal, das Parteien-Spektrum in Hamburg. Die SPD ist allein regierend seit Februar letzten Jahres. Die FDP ist auch in Hamburg noch im Parlament, die CDU auch und die Grünen und die Linke. Damit haben wir die abgefeiert. In dem Bündnis waren davon die Grünen, die Linke und die Piraten, die ja außerparlamentarisch sind, die auch übrigens alle drei sehr gut zusammengearbeitet haben. Die Parteien, auf die es ankam, waren im Endeffekt die SPD und um einen gemeinsamen Antrag durchzukriegen, dann halt FDP und CDU. Die FDP hat von vornherein einen Beobachter geschickt, wollte sich aber nicht zu dem Bündnis bekennen, aber ein Beobachter war immer da. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so typisch ist, wie auch immer. Die CDU hat sich relativ spät damit beschäftigt. Die Oppositionspartei hat das erst mal so angeguckt. Als wir dann nach diesen vier Wochen Verhandlungen mit der SPD, mit der Regierungspartei, dann irgendwann diesen Gegenvorschlag hatten und damit auch im Bündnis durchgekommen waren, dann gab es halt eine Einladung an die anderen Parteien, über diesen Vorschlag auch mit abzustimmen und darüber zu beraten. Dann gab es dann noch mal so ein Allparteien-Gespräch, daraufhin wurden noch Anmerkungen gemacht, Sachen, die geändert werden sollten und dann haben sich zu unserer großen Überraschung halt alle Parteien, die in Hamburg in der Bürgerschaft sitzen, darauf geeinigt, dieses Gesetz in die Bürgerschaft zu bringen und gemeinschaftlich einstimmig zu beschließen.
Das war für uns auch ein seltener Fall, egal in welchen Landes- oder Bundesparlamenten. Das ist nicht so häufig und umso besser eigentlich, breiter Konsens.
Vor allem bindet sie das auch daran und egal, wie da die nächste Regierung aussieht, sie haben alle zugestimmt, sie haben alle dieses Gesetz selber reingebracht.
Ist es denn so, dass du sagen würdest, politische Arbeit ist super, hat funktioniert, muss man auf jeden Fall, müssen das alle machen?
Na ich sage für mich politische Arbeit ist super, hat funktioniert und ich mach da gerne weiter. Muss man machen, kann ich natürlich keinem vorschreiben, aber ich empfehle jedem das mal auszuprobieren.
Jetzt hört sich das ja wirklich sozusagen wie das schöne Märchen an. Also Hacker beschließt, den Computer zu verlassen, macht politische Arbeit und oh mein Gott, alles klappt und alle Parteien sagen super. Hat das auch eine Rolle gespielt, dass dieses Transparenzgesetz, wie ihr gerade schon gesagt habt, das ist halt so Zeitgeist und eigentlich verliert man nichts, wenn man dem zustimmt. Hat das geholfen?
Ja sogar noch im Gegenteil. Also Zeit und Ort waren perfekt und es ist ja nicht nur man verliert nichts, wenn man dem nicht zustimmt, sondern es ist ja sogar welche Partei will denn wiedergewählt werden und stellt sich heute in ein Parlament und sagt wir sind komplett gegen Transparenz und wir wollen alles so lassen, wie es ist. Damit schneiden die sich ein bisschen ins eigene Fleisch.
Ok, also sozusagen geschickt und auch zur rechten Zeit am rechten Ort.
Es gab auch Probleme, die würden wir nicht verschweigen.
Das wollte ich gerade mal in der nächsten Frage gewesen. Jetzt hätten wir doch gerne noch sagen, es gibt ja bei Rezensionen immer die Plus- und Minuspunkte. Gab es irgendwas, wo du sagen würdest, ok, wenn ihr auch in Politik anfällt? Das war eine Ecke, da hätte ich gerne früher gewusst, dass es so und so läuft.
Na ja, gut, also gerade in Bezug auf das Gesetz war natürlich der Kompromiss. Einen Kompromiss, dabei verliert man immer. Aber es verlieren halt auch beide dabei. Von daher muss man halt immer abwägen, kann ich diesen Kompromiss eingehen, will ich das drangeben, dafür kann ich was anderes retten und so weiter und so fort. Es gibt oder gab auch Stimmen im Bündnis, die gesagt haben, das ist der äußerste Kompromiss, weiter gehen wir nicht. Dann gehen wir lieber auf die Straße und sammeln die Unterschriften für den Volksentscheid. Heute am Tag haben wir das Volksbegehren auch noch nicht zurückgezogen, weil das Gesetz noch nicht im Gesetzesblatt veröffentlicht ist. Da warten wir noch, bis das wirklich in trockenen Tüchern ist und haben uns jederzeit diese Tür offen gelassen, doch Unterschriften sammeln zu gehen.
Okay, also das mit der Kompromisslosigkeit. Apropos das, Hacker tendieren ja auch manchmal dazu, so zu sagen, also extreme Lösungen zu fordern, wenn es um Politik geht. Gab es da innerhalb des Clubs oder von Hackerumfällen, hast du da irgendwie sozusagen auch Anfeindungen gehabt, im Sinne von sich überhaupt mit der Politik zu beschäftigen?
Spannenderweise gar nicht, aus den Hacker-Kreisen. Da ist es eigentlich ziemlich gut aufgenommen worden. Und auch im Club habe ich da großen Rückhalt gehabt. Oder wir, weil wir waren ja mit mehreren Leuten daran beteiligt. Ich war halt nur derjenige, der zuletzt weggerannt ist, als es darum ging, da eine Vertrauensperson zu finden, die zehn Monate ihrer Zeit dafür reinsteckt. Das darf man halt auch nicht vergessen. So eine Kampagnenplanung heißt halt im Endeffekt auch oder das geht halt auch nur, weil Leute wie Mehr Demokratie halt einfach ein Büro haben mit zwei Vollzeitaktivisten, noch eine Praktikantin dazu geholt haben. Und für mich als Vertrauensperson hieß es halt, auf vier Tage Woche reduzieren und einen Tag in der Woche Vollzeit da im Büro zu sitzen.
Nein, muss man aber sagen, das muss nicht unbedingt sein. Wenn man es manchmal auf breitere Beine stellen kann, kann man es auch komplett ehrenamtlich hinkriegen. Da waren wir auch Beispiele. Aber natürlich, hier war auch ein gewisser zeitlicher Druck da. Das sollte man nicht vergessen. Und es stand ja auch immer noch zur Debatte, dass man tatsächlich ein Bürgerbegehren macht. Und dann wird es echt schwierig, das nur ehrenamtlich zu machen. Das sieht man ja auch in anderen Bürgerbegehrenbeispielen.
Genau, das ist halt der Punkt. Also du brauchst da schon Manpower dahinter und musst halt auch was stemmen. Aber im Club selber war eigentlich von vornherein ein gewisser Rückhalt da. Es haben sich auch viele Leute inhaltlich noch mal gemeldet, haben gesagt, Mensch, könnt ihr das noch reinbringen? Oder wie macht ihr das? Aber Ablehnung in der Form aus dem Clubumfeld kam halt nicht. Also es kam nie dieses, red nicht mit denen, das sind Politiker. Das kam lustigerweise teilweise aus Jugendorganisationen von Parteien, also oder auch von Uni-Hochschulgruppen, die die Politik an Unis machen, die dann sagten, im Sinne der Weltrevolution wäre es also totaler Blödsinn, wenn Bürger jetzt Gesetze schreiben. Wo ich mir dann auch denke, auf die Weltrevolution warte ich jetzt auch schon 30 Jahre, die könnte langsam mal.
Das ist glaube ich auch so ein bisschen, wir haben natürlich mittlerweile auch so strukturelle Kritiker, die alles, was der Club macht, gerne kritisieren, ob das immer sehr sachlich ist. Ich glaube, da darf man sich auch nicht irritieren lassen. Man darf zwar nicht blind werden, irgendwie fückertig und muss dir aufnehmen, aber von irgendwelchen Ecken gibt es immer Ärger. Ich finde es nicht weiter wild. Also vor allen Dingen, wenn man im Bündnis ist, gleicht es sich auch so ein bisschen aus. Man redet ja auch übereinander und dann kann man auch nicht ganz falsch abbiegen.
Aber ist es noch mal eine neue Erfahrung gewesen, diesen Kompromiss einzugehen?
Na ja, natürlich ist es eine neue Erfahrung. Also bisher waren wir ja ganz häufig nur in der Position, wir sind dagegen. Da gibt es irgendwas, ACTA, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Überwachung, ETC, ETC und uns fiel die Rolle zu, auf die Straße zu gehen und auf Deutsch gesagt das Maul aufzumachen und zu sagen, wir sind dagegen. Und jetzt waren wir halt einfach in diesem umgekehrten, konstruktiven Prozess drin. Und haben gesagt, wir sind nicht nur dagegen, was da läuft, sondern wir machen halt auch was dran. Und das war halt eine extrem gute Erfahrung. Einfach mal nicht jetzt wieder zum 300. Mal auf die Straße zu gehen und die selben Transparente hochzuhalten oder unterschiedliche Transparente mit den Leuten, die man auf jeder Demo trifft, sondern einfach zu sagen, wir machen jetzt was, hier ist das, was wir wirklich durchbringen wollen. Wir verändern jetzt aktiv was. Und das war für mich die wichtigste Erfahrung daran.
Dann sollte man aus meiner Sicht auch nicht um einen generalisieren. Dann denke ich, diese Form von Boykotten, die es gegeben hat, die Proteste, auch die lauten und überhaupt auch im CCC viele Aktionen, die sich ganz destruktiv an das Thema ranmachen, um die kaputt zu machen oder um sie zu durchleuchten, die sind oft auch in den letzten Monaten und Jahren von Erfolg gekrönt gewesen. Es gibt überhaupt keine Form von konstruktiver Mitarbeit unsererseits, etwa wenn es um Vorwärtsentsprechung geht, wenn man es aus ganz prinzipiellen Gründen ablehnt. Oder auch wenn es um Computerwanzen geht. Oder auch bei Wahlcomputern war sehr wenig konstruktive Mitarbeit möglich, weil es einfach weitere klare prinzipielle Bedenken gibt. Und da sind oft erst mal bestehende Systeme, die muss man hacken. Das ist immer ein destruktiver Prozess. Das finde ich nicht unbedingt negativ. Denn manche Dinge, nennen wir sie mal beim Namen, die Vorurteilsentsprechung, Akta oder auch Körpervermessung, die Zwangsweise, also Biometrie, die sind abzulehnen. Da ist bei uns auch eine ganz klare Mehrheit. Aber wir haben halt in den letzten Monaten neben diesem transparenten Prozess mit diesem Transparenzgesetz, was ein großer Erfolg war, auch andere Beispiele, wo wir ein bisschen diesen Paradigma kippen. Das hacken wir immer nur dagegen sein. Ich glaube, da sind noch ein paar mehr Beispiele. Also aktuell haben wir sogar noch ein paar mehr.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle kurz unterbrechen, weil ich dazu tatsächlich gleich kommen würde, was es noch gibt. Ich würde noch ganz kurz das Transparenzgesetz abschließen wollen mit der Frage in Hamburg. Also wie gesagt, das muss noch im offiziellen Blättchen gedruckt werden, damit es gültig ist. Juristische Formalität, die hoffentlich sozusagen keine irgendwie Schwierigkeit machen wird. Jetzt ist das ja ein schönes Beispiel. Und Zeit und Ort waren gerade richtig. Wie sieht es denn jetzt mit dem Rest vom Land aus?
Na ja, wir haben ja schon viel Feedback gekriegt, viel Presse darüber. Ich habe aus Berlin im Tagesspiegel gelesen, dass das Land Berlin jetzt ganz dringend nachziehen will, weil so weit entfernt seien sie ja nicht davon. Sehr lobenswert. Also wenn das wirklich nur eine kleine Hürde ist, dann bitte immer ran. Und in anderen Bundesländern laufen die Kampagnen halt auch an. Also da gibt es wirklich aus der Politik Meldungen, ja, sowas in der Art wollen wir auch. Es gibt auch Bürgerbewegungen, die sagen, Mensch, das starten wir jetzt hier auch. Also da passiert eine Menge. Und naja, für mich wäre halt wünschenswert, wenn es direkt auf Bundesebene kommt, weil da muss man nicht in jedem Land einzeln kämpfen.
Na ja, es gab einen kleinen zeitlichen Zufall, der dem sehr entgegenkommt. Die Informationsfreiheitsbeauftragten aus Bund und Ländern, fast alle, aber nicht alle Bundesländer, aber fast alle, mit Peter Schar, der neben dem Datenschutz noch die Informationsfreiheit betreut, die hätten sich gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo dieser Erfolg öffentlich wurde, getroffen. Die hatten eine zweitegige Tagung und haben über die Vergangenheit und Zukunft der Informationsfreiheit gesprochen. Dazu kommt noch mehr, außer nur die Informationsfreiheitsgesetze. Weil wir haben in manchen Bereichen, zum Beispiel Umwelt, haben wir eigene Informationsfreiheitsgesetze. Also da gibt es ja unterschiedliche Zoos an Gesetzen. Und da platzte halt gerade in deren Tagung auch die Nachricht. Und es war, glaube ich, deshalb ganz günstig, dass die sich darüber unterhalten konnten. Das ist schon wirklich ein Paradigmenwechsel. Und Peter Schar hat da gerade seinen Bericht fertig. Der guckt ja immer so in gewissen Abständen drauf. Wie wirkt denn das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz? Und da traten halt auch so die Schwächen zutage, die ja durchaus sichtbar sind. Insofern ist dieser Wechsel zu, wir machen es von uns aus, gehabt zur richtigen Zeit. Also da muss man einfach wieder auch nicht unterschätzen, dass es einen Druck gibt durch den Erfolg der Piraten, die, ich glaube, vielen anderen Parteien schlicht auch so ein bisschen Angst machen. Und dann auch noch der Effekt, dass sehr viel Presse und Rundfunk, Fernsehen darüber berichtet. Aber auch generell über die Beteiligung und Transparenz. Das ist gerade eben die richtige Zeit.
Also ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn ihr jetzt gerade, also so Berlin, ich sag nochmal Wasserverträge, möglicherweise sind auch beim Flughafen ein paar Dinge passiert, die man möglicherweise gerne wissen würde durch so ein Transparenzgesetz. Die Zeit ist günstig, also wenn ihr euch gerade engagieren wollt für eine positive Erfahrung, möglicherweise ist es an dieser Stelle nicht zu spät. Wir machen jetzt eine ganz kleine Pause und haben damit das Transparenzgesetz aber abgeschlossen und kommen dann gleich noch zu weiteren konstruktiven Einbringungen, wie Hacker Politik machen können. Holy Bleep von Mizuki's Last Chance hier im Chaosradio ist Creative-Commons-Musik. Das heißt, ihr könnt euch einfach runterladen. Den Link dazu gibt's irgendwo draußen in diesem Internet, von dem wir alle reden.
Sitz.
Heute Chaos Radio mit zwei Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club, nämlich Dodger, hallo. Und Constanze.
Hallo.
Und wir haben in der ersten Stunde über das Transparenzgesetz gesprochen. Das Transparenzgesetz ist in vielen Hinsicht ein Positivbeispiel, zum Beispiel, weil es sehr selten ist, dass Bürger Politik machen wollen und damit richtig durchkommen. Oder dass es auch, zumindest bis jetzt sehr selten war, dass in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung vielleicht auch das Hacker konstruktive Kritik machen. Normalerweise kennt man Hacker und den Club auch, dass er sagt, Entschuldigung, sie haben diese Technologie und die ist kaputt. Und es ist selten, dass sie sagen, wir haben hier eine Idee, wir finden das ganz geil, was haltet ihr davon, lasst uns doch mal mitmachen. Das ist natürlich nicht ganz so einseitig. Es gab gerade in den letzten zwei, drei Jahren so ein paar Beispiele, wo das auch versucht wurde, nicht immer von Erfolg gekrönt. Und solche Beispiele würden wir jetzt gerne noch mal kurz zusammentragen. Wenn ihr noch was dazu zu sagen habt oder wenn ihr denkt, hey, das ist ein Projekt, das müsste man eigentlich mal versuchen, habt ihr eine Idee, könnt ihr gerne anrufen. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer. So, Frau Kurz, Sie hatten ja gerade schon angefangen mit Dinge, die Leute mit technischem Sachverstand versucht haben, konstruktiv zu bewegen.
Ja, Herr Richter.
Und was wäre da noch so am Start?
Wir haben halt einige andere Beispiele, über die wir gerne mal kurz reden können, die aber natürlich alle nicht so richtig die Parameter von diesem Transfarenzgesetz treffen. Nämlich ging ganz schnell, war total erfolgreich, mit ganz wenig Kompromissen und auf der ganzen Linie positiv. Viel andere Beispiele, die man von diesem konstruktiven Lobbyismus kennt, sind entweder noch am Beginn eines Prozesses mit langem Atem, oder sie sind auch nicht so erfolgreich gewesen.
Da würde ich gleich noch mal vorher was anderes kennen wollen. Du hast jetzt schon zum wiederholten Mal Lobbyismus gesagt. Das ist ja auch so ein Begriff. Man verbindet mit Lobbyist, das ist der Typ, also im Anzug schlüpst mit dem dicken Geldkoffer, der durch Brüsseler oder Berliner Gebäude schleicht.
Ja, oder wie eine schneimige Frisur hat.
Genau, und der Politiker sagt, das erklärt das Gelendheimer. Der Politiker sagt so, was für Gesetze sie machen sollen. Aber Lobbyismus ist im Prinzip einfach nur inhaltliche Arbeit, also in diesem Falle zu verstehen, am Politiker.
Ja, im Wesentlichen eigentlich eine Interessenpolitik. Man hat ein Ziel und versucht, über das Mittel der Beeinflussung der politischen Parteien, das durchzusetzen.
Also Beeinflussung ist, das muss man halt mal sagen, ist halt nicht sozusagen, wir hauen dich oder wir geben dir Geld oder Saumagen aus, sondern ist, wir bieten dir inhaltliche Angaben und möglicherweise Argumente, die du nicht widersprechen kannst.
Naja, es ist nicht nur inhaltlich. Also an Dodgers Beispiel in Hamburg, beim Transparenzgesetz kann man deutlich sehen, dass er auch andere Mittel verwandt hat. Wir haben das auf seinem Twitter-Account nachlesen können. Er hat sie etwa durch Kleidung beeindrucken wollen.
Na ja, beeindrucken ist übertrieben, aber ich habe ein schönes Schakett.
Er hat tatsächlich einige Stunden über seinen Kleiderschrank getweetet.
Das war dann bei der Anhörung, oder?
Nein, das war bei der Pressekonferenz.
Bei der Pressekonferenz hat sie gesetzt.
Das war sehr erheiternd.
Erster großer Auftritt.
Das ist schon inhaltlich. Man versucht halt einfach wirklich Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten. Gar nicht mal in dem typischen Lobbyisten-Sinn. Man holt sich da wieder mal die Schnittchenveranstaltungen ran, sondern man hat eigentlich Gemeinwohlinteressen im Blick. Es geht ja bei uns nie um irgendwelche kommerziellen Hintergründe. Deswegen sind natürlich auch die Projekte nicht immer alle so erfolgreich wie in Hamburg. Müssen wir mal zu. Wir haben aber auch dazugelernt. Ich glaube, das ist ja auch ein Prozess. Ich denke, davon wird mehr kommen. Auch weil sich mehr Leute beteiligen können.
Also gerade so an Dingen, die konstruktiv waren, aber nicht so richtig abgeflogen sind, möchte ich jetzt mal kurz Kulturwertmark sagen, oder?
Ich würde das im Nachhinein nicht so sehen. Der Kulturwertmark ist ein Vorschlag, den wir vor ein bisschen über einem Jahr gemacht haben, der ja auch ein Diskussionsvorschlag ist. Ich würde den auf keinen Fall abschreiben, weil ich glaube, das ist ein Projekt mit langer Phase, wo wir einfach auch Durchhaltevermögen haben müssen. Die Kulturwertmark hat insofern, sie hat eigentlich einen gewissen Hacker-Input, weil wir von einem technischen Denken ausgegangen sind. Und zwar ist die Kulturwertmark eine Idee für ein zukünftiges Vergütungssystem für Urheber. Wir haben uns also überlegt, wie man mit heutigen technischen Methoden die doch über kommende Regelung, wie sie hier gesetzlich, aber auch von einer reinen Bezahlung der Urheber besteht, revolutionieren könnte. Und wir haben uns überlegt, dass dafür ein Micropaymentsystem, ein sinnvolles technologisches Gut sein könnte dafür. Und zwar, dass man also tatsächlich zwischen dem, der Kunst im allerweitesten Sinne oder kreativer Arbeit rezipiert und dem, der sie erschaffen hat, ein Band herstellt, nämlich Kleinstbeträge zu transferieren. Das war die Idee. Da hängt noch ein großer Rattenschwanz dran.
Ich wollte mal kurz in Normalsprache übersetzen.
Also Kleinstbeträge von demjenigen, der die Kunst oder die Kultur schafft.
Es geht halt darum, dass Leute ein monatliches Volumen haben und im Prinzip Dinge liken können, also Dinge klicken können, die ihnen gefällt. Dann wird das Geld, was monatlich jeder einzahlen muss oder kann, das ist nach Modell unterschiedlich, verteilt auf die Künstler. Ihr habt das veröffentlicht und habt dann gesagt, guckt mal Leute, das ist ein Diskussionsvorschlag. Die Reaktion, die ich wahrgenommen habe, ist, das kann man gar nicht so umsetzen.
Was ist denn das? Die Reaktion war eigentlich im Wesentlichen, was ist denn das für ein Bobername? Also wir haben festgestellt, dass es natürlich auch im Club durchaus zu frustrernd und auch zu Demotivation kommt, wenn die Leute statt über den Inhalt tatsächlich zu diskutieren waren. Und wir haben auch total tolles Feedback bekommen, muss ich schon mal sagen. Also auf Twitter war das selber ein Bobername. Dabei war der, das war jetzt erstmal nur, um überhaupt irgendwas zu haben. Aber man lernt nach ein paar Monaten damit auch wieder konstruktiv umzugehen. Wir haben heute eine Gruppe total motivierter Studenten von einer Hochschule für Gestaltung. Die denken sich ein Konzept aus mit uns zusammen. Und die arbeiten an neuen, griffigeren Namen. Also man muss da manchmal über diese erste Reaktion hinwegsehen. Es ist auch nicht dogmatisch. Wir sehen dieses Modell nicht als fertig an, sondern als Diskussionsgrundlage, weil einfach eine gewisse Genervtheit nach einer Dekade Stillstand im Club herrschte. Ich glaube, es ist zwar nicht so ein schönes Beispiel, aber da werden wir in fünf Jahren nochmal drüber reden können, da glaube ich schon, dass es durchaus noch Chancen hat.
Aber braucht man sozusagen, wenn man Politik macht, auch ein dickes Fell?
Ach, natürlich. So wie Dutch jetzt beschrieben hat, ist es ja nicht der Normalfall. Ich finde das alles so toll, idealtypisch. Das hat auch so hingehauen. Das ist total toll.
Das tut mir leid, hätte ich da mehr Stress reinbringen sollen.
Ich bin da fast ein bisschen neidisch, weil natürlich viele von den politischen Projekten, die wir in den letzten Jahren so betreut haben, jetzt ich selbst, aber auch andere im Club, wo ich es live mitbekommen habe, die sind natürlich keineswegs so motivierend und so erfolgreich. Dann haben sie sich oft auch in der Bundespolitik dann manifestiert. Da ist es längst nicht so angenehm, überhaupt nicht so konstruktiv, sondern wesentlich festgefahrener, nicht so schön. Dort hat er eben beschrieben, wie im Justizausschuss in Hamburg, weil man den typischen Ausschuss im Bundestag sieht, also Justizausschuss oder Unterausschuss Neue Medien, da ist es keineswegs so konstruktiv. Und es ist auch oft so, wenn man eine Anhörung hat, dann fragt die Partei, die einen Experten einlädt, nur ihren Experten oder auch viele Parlamentarier, hören gar nicht zu, also beteiligen sich letztlich gar nicht an der Debatte, sondern klicken auf ihren iPhones oder auf ihren Computern rum. Und Prinzip geben oder geben nur die Parteimannung wieder. Also es ist nicht immer so schön angenehm wie in Hamburg. Oder aber auch, dass von vornherein klar ist, dass jeder Vorschlag, der nicht auf Linie ist, der Partei abgelehnt wird. Also so schön konstruktiv.
Also egal, was man sagt, wenn es nicht zur Farbe passt, dann ist es so.
Also die Rituale sind einfach stärker. Und dann diese elenden Geschäftsordnungstricks.
Aber lohnt es sich trotzdem, das zu machen? Club, ihr habt doch Experten. Komm mal bitte vor, denen du den Ausschuss hast. Hast du da ein Beispiel für?
Wir haben in jüngster Zeit das wieder gemacht. Wir hatten eine ganze Zeit lang überhaupt keine Stellungnahmen schriftlicher Art. Für gesetzgebende Ausschüsse mehr abgegeben, weil wir einfach für vergebene Zeit gehalten haben.
Kannst du noch mal kurz erläutern, wie sowas funktioniert? Also wo der Punkt ist, wo der Club dann gefragt wird. Schreib mal bitte was.
Ja, das ist unterschiedlich. Aber im Wesentlichen sieht der Prozess so aus. Dass es eine Idee für ein Gesetzgebungsverfahren gibt und irgendein gesetzgebender Ausschuss, der sich darum kümmert. Also in der Regel ist es eben etwas netzpolitikennahes. Oft eben Justiz oder innen. Und dann ist es so, dass jede Partei dort sich zu Anhörungen Experten einladen kann. Das ist aber meistens schon der mittlere Entstehungsprozess des Gesetzes. Das heißt, dass es meistens schon konkrete Vorschläge gibt. Manchmal auch nicht. Manchmal wird auch früher debattiert, aber in der Regel hat man schon irgendwas Schriftliches vorliegen. Dann bittet man die Experten um Stellungnahmen. Das ist meistens mit vorformulierten Fragen, die man dann beantworten kann, zum Teil oder vollständig. Dann gibt es eine mögliche Anhörung, die in der Regel 2-3 Stunden ist. Manchmal auch länger. Man gibt auch schriftlich die Stellungnahme ab. Dann gesellt man sich zu dem anderen Stapel Papier.
Ich würde gerade sagen, wird man dann auch instrumentalisiert? Also im Sinne von, wir haben ja die Leute vom Club jetzt gehört, sind ja alle Fachmeinungen vertreten?
Das ist halt auch ein Vorwurf, der uns wieder gemacht wurde, wo wir auch manchmal selbst den Eindruck hatten, dass es letztlich nichts bringt außer Arbeit und dass man da eigentlich gegen Wände redet. Deswegen haben wir das auch lange nicht mehr gemacht. In jüngster Zeit haben wir das wieder gemacht. Das hat auch mit dem Unterausschuss neue Medien zu tun. Der hat nämlich ein relativ offenes Konzept. Die Sitzung kann man verfolgen. Da gibt es einen Hashtag für Twitter. Das heißt, da ist mehr Debatte, da kommt schon mal eine Frage, die auf Twitter gestellt wurde, direkt in den Ausschuss. Das ist also offener und macht dadurch auch mehr Spaß, wenn man sich beteiligt, wenn man zumindest eine gewisse Resonanz hat. Und nicht so sehr diese festgefahrenen Rituale. Natürlich war er trotzdem irgendwie Siegfried Kauder von der CDU. Und hat da seinen Schuh, also die Rede, die er sowieso immer ablässt. Aber das ist dann eher erheiternd, weil man die Twitter-Kommentare wenigstens noch hat, die auch verstehen, wie inhaltlich sinnlos gerade war.
Ist das denn so, dass man dann quasi auch in kleinen Politik macht, indem man sich als Clubmitglied oder als Hacker dann nur an solchen Sachen beteiligt, wo man denkt, das hat auch irgendwie Erfolgs-Aussicht?
Na, das ist ja, na, Dodger hat eben so angedeutet, wie das so ist mit der ehrenamtlichen Arbeit und einfach auch der Zeit, die man reinsteckt. Ich meine, er selbst hatte jetzt wieder gerade gemerkt, wir im Club, wir haben natürlich für die verschiedenen Themen auch einfach nur eine begrenzte Manpower. Und ich glaube, da ist das Effizienzdenken in Bezug auf, wo stecken wir jetzt Zeit rein, ziemlich ausgeprägt. Wir überlegen uns schon, welche Kämpfe kann man vielleicht gewinnen, wo macht es Sinn oder wo redet man eigentlich gegen Wände und braucht das auch nicht tun. Und wenn man zum Beispiel eine Stellungnahme schreibt, das sollte man nicht unterschätzen. Wie viel Aufriss ist sowas? Na ja, in der Regel ist es auf jeden Fall immer eine Arbeit, die mehrere Leute zusammen machen. Da schreibt da irgendwie keiner alleine. Also wir benutzen da kollaborative Werkzeuge auch schon lange.
Und dann bevorzugt nachts, weil man ja noch einen Dayjob hat. Also ich kann mich an die letzte erinnern, da ging es um ein Landesparlament, wo eine der Parteien einen sehr lustigen Open-Data-Vorschlag eingebracht hatte, der eigentlich nur die Übersetzung der Webseite der Open Knowledge Foundation war und die Grundsätze auch noch falsch übersetzt hatten. Und da haben wir uns dann halt auch, also die Leute aus dem Bundesland im Club haben halt gesagt, du, die haben uns hier gefragt, ob wir da eine Stellungnahme abgeben können. Und das haben wir dann halt gelesen, haben gesagt, ja, okay, da muss man jetzt eine Stellungnahme abgeben. Und die haben das auch mit so einer schönen Frist gemacht von drei Tagen.
Ja, genau, man darf die Fristen nicht vergessen.
Weil die gehen ja davon aus, dass du irgendwie Vollzeitaktivist bist und an deinem Rechner sitzt und darauf wartest, dass irgendjemand sagt, so bitte schreib hier mal ein Pamphlet. Und dann sieht das halt so aus, dass dann vier Leute nachts in einem Bett arbeiten und dann morgens noch mal eine Stunde schlafen und dann wieder an die Arbeit gehen.
Es ist auch dann noch so, in der Regel möchte man ja flankieren mit der Informierung der Öffentlichkeit. Also jetzt der klubinternen Öffentlichkeit, aber auch der netzpolitischen Öffentlichkeit, aber auch allen Zeitungen. Also kommt ja immer noch der Medienaspekt dazu davor, dabei und danach. Natürlich stellen sich dann wieder Fragen. Und da ist immer noch ein bisschen mehr als das reine Schreiben. Und man muss natürlich auch jemanden, den man vorzeigen kann, dann da hinsetzen. Das macht ja auch nicht jeder Hacker. Man muss mal sehen, dass nicht alle Hacker bereit sind, sich da irgendwie mit einem Sacko hinzusetzen.
Also wer Politik macht, braucht keine anderen Hobbys.
Ach na, also, dort, wie sieht es mit dir aus? Ich habe schon noch andere Hobbys.
Na, ich war, lass mich überlegen, ich war Minigolfspieler.
Wir lassen uns einfach mal so stehen und halten fest, dass es schon zeitaufwendig ist. Ich würde gerne noch mal auf die, zurückkommen auf die Frage von vorhin. Nennen mal bitte noch kurz, damit man das möglicherweise auch sich selbst mal antun kann, wenn man sich zu dem Thema interessiert. Gerade laufende Dinge, die konstruktiv sind und wo ihr die Finger mit im Spiel habt.
Also was mir sehr persönlich auch sehr wichtig ist, ist, dass der Gesetzentwurf, der gerade fertig wurde, den findet man aktuell bei netzpolitik.org und der ist im Wesentlichen geschrieben von Ulf Böhmeier über die Störerhaftung. Das ist schon lange ein Anliegen des CCC. Wir wollen uns beteiligen, auch über den Sommer, einer ordentlichen Kampagne. Also ich hoffe, dass wir auch Parteien finden, die sich anschließen. Das ist ein fertig formulierter Gesetzentwurf, der aus meiner Sicht innerlich sehr gut ist, der vor allen Dingen aber mit großer juristischer Expertise zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Man muss natürlich Unterstützung finden.
Wir haben einen Gesetzentwurf zur Störerhaftung, wenn du noch die Güte hättest, kurz zu erklären.
Hier geht es um die Frage, was man eigentlich demjenigen androht, der Netzzugang zur Verfügung stellt. Wenn man sich sein Netz bei der Telekom oder bei Vodafone klickt, so haben die gewisse Privilegien. Nämlich, dass sie erstmal für die Inhalte, die darüber gehen, nicht haften. Das gibt es für kleine Provider so nicht. Wenn ich meinen WLAN zu Hause öffne, dann muss ich eventuell mit Strafen rechnen, wenn jemand, der diesen WLAN mitbenutzt, dort irgendwelche rechtlich bedenklichen Dinge tut. Dieses Privileg, was große Provider haben, würden wir gern für kleine Provider auch sehen, weil wir es für ein zukunftsträchtiges Projekt halten.
Weil dann einfach jeder seinen WLAN aufmachen kann und nicht Angst haben muss, dass er verknackt wird, weil irgend ein Spinner meine Little Pony voll im Motor geladen hat.
Die Idee verbindet sich auch mit Ideen von Freifunk und auch mit Initiativen, die diese Rechtssicherheit mal bräuchten. Auch der Entwurf dieses Vorhabens ist schon einige Monate alt. Das heißt, da gibt es auch einen langen Prozess. Das wird nicht so einfach sein wie in Hamburg, bestimmt nicht. Aber ich denke, es lohnt sich. Da müssen wir eben dranbleiben. Bisher gibt es erst mal einen Entwurf, und die Digi gestern hat den veröffentlicht. Aber wir gucken mal, ob wir da einen Mitstreiter finden. Ich würde mich da auch gerne selber engagieren. Ich denke, im Club wird es da eine ganze Menge Leute geben, weil es auch viele Freifunker gibt. Es gibt aber noch mehr. Ich finde es ganz interessant, dass ich in letzter Zeit auch ein bisschen darum bezahlt habe, dass ich ganz gute, konstruktive Sachen mit dem Crowdfunding ergeben habe, also für politische Kampagnen Geld zu sammeln, dass sich eine Zeit lang Leute fulltime darum kümmern können. Das hat in letzter Zeit immer mal ganz gut funktioniert. Und das letzte Beispiel, was wir uns vorher noch mal überlegt haben, ist natürlich die Stiftung Datenschutz. Die haben wir lange gefordert. Und vor zwei, drei Tagen hat sich ergeben, dass die Regierungskoalition jetzt tatsächlich mal einen Vorschlag gemacht hat. Sie hatte den übernommen in ihren Koalitionsvertrag auf Betreiben der FDP. Das ist eine langjährige Forderung. Und jetzt ist erstmal ein Vorschlag da. Der Vorschlag ist ein bisschen unterirdisch, aber zumindest sieht man, dass so langjährige, also steht der Tropfenhöhe den Stein, wollte ich fast sagen. Also man kann versuchen, darüber ein bisschen was zu schaffen. Ist halt alles noch nicht so perfekt. Die Stiftung Datenschutz soll in erster Linie eine Transparenz über Datenschutzgebaren von Unternehmen und Behörden darstellen. Das ist in der jetzigen Idee noch nicht so ganz da. Man vergleitet ganz gern mit einer Stiftung Warentests, wo man eben auch eine gewisse Vergleichbarkeit herstellt und eine Transparenz, wo der Verbraucher sich informieren kann. Und so vergleichbar hatten wir eine Stiftung Datenschutz vorgeschlagen. Das ist tatsächlich Jahrzehnte alt, das Konzept. Das geht auf Spirosymethes zurück. Also, drei Jahrzehnte schon. Wir hoffen eigentlich nur, dass die Nachfolgerregierung das aufgreifen wird. Denn bisher, man kann ja den Vorschlag von einer Koalition jetzt mal nachlesen, finden wir ein bisschen dürftig, weil die beschränken die Idee mehr auf so einen Gütesiegel Datenschutz, was uns glaube ich nicht so sehr weiterbringt. Aber zumindest ist die Idee mal in den Köpfen.
Was wollt ihr? Was ist der Gegenvorschlag der Konstruktive?
Wir wollen eigentlich vor allen Dingen so eine Art von Vergleichbarkeit herstellen, wie wir bei Warentestern kennen. Dass man zum Beispiel zwei, drei Plattformen hat und tatsächlich sinnvoll und einfach vergleichen kann, wie sind denn die Datenschutze gebaren, dass man auch diese langen AGBs, die Datenschutzerklärung, verstehen kann. Aus meiner Sicht muss es eine Kombination aus technischer Perspektive und juristischer sein, sodass man wirklich einfach mit diesem Tool einen mündigen Verbraucher wiederherstellen kann, der selber entscheidet und zwar informiert entscheidet und sich nicht selbst da so durchklicken muss. Es gibt so eine Ansätze auch schon von anderen Organisationen. Die Verbraucherschutzzentralen bieten da teilweise an. Es gibt Plattformen wie Sicher im Netz, wo man sich ein bisschen informieren kann. Wir hätten halt gern, dass der Staat das unterstützt, auch mit Geld. Denn das kostet viel Zeit, das juristisch und technisch alle zu untersuchen. Das ändert sich sehr schnell. Alleine, wenn wir an Facebook denken, ist ja alle paar Monate wieder mal eine Änderung. Und da muss man auch hinterher sein, das sollte aktuell sein. Ich finde, da muss der Staat, wenn er schon keine ordentlichen Gesetze im Bereich Datenschutz macht, da mal hinterher sein, wenigstens die Verbraucher zu informieren, sodass die auch danach entscheiden können. Ich finde das ein wichtiges Anliegen, was übrigens auch, was für alle diese Gesetze gilt, nach Europa getragen werden muss. Denn Deutschland ist gesetzgeberisch nach wie vor ein Vorbild. Und wenn wir das schaffen, bestimmte Dinge durchzusetzen oder auch abzuwehren, ist es natürlich auch immer über Europa und darüber hinaus wichtig.
Okay, dann haben wir also doch die, wie heißt das, Datenschutz. Ich würde jetzt gerne auch nochmal ganz kurz das andere beleuchten wollen, die andere Seite des politischen Aktivismus von Hackern. Und das ist, entschuldigen Sie, Sie haben eine Technologie, die müssen wir mal kaputt machen. Könnt ihr das mal an einem Beispiel in den letzten Jahren erläutern, wie das vonstatten geht? Also weil, um es nochmal zu rekapitulieren jetzt die Sendung, ist es ja so, es gab dieses Positivbeispiel, Leute setzen sich zusammen, arbeiten einen Gesetzesvorschlag aus und dann wird darüber geredet, da kann man auch Kompromisse machen und so. Und dann hat das ein gutes Ende genommen. Bei diesem Wir machen deine Technologie kaputt, gilt es ja, die Politik davon zu überzeugen, dass nicht nur, dass es da irgendwie einen Kompromiss zu finden gibt, sondern man muss die Idee fallen lassen. Also das ist ja das, was da eigentlich erreicht werden soll. Gibt es da ein Beispiel, an dem ihr es illustrieren könnt?
Es gibt natürlich sehr viele jetzt.
Jetzt nur eins.
Ja, eins reicht. Ich meine, viele werden die auch kennen. Also die Netzsperren, etwa auch die Vorzeitenspeicherung. Als Beispiel, wo wir heute schon so viele Hamburger Sachen haben, wäre natürlich der Wahlstift ganz gut. Denn hier war es eher so, dass man sich auch ein bisschen prinzipielle Gedanken gemacht hat. Also ist diese Technik grundsätzlich zu unterstützen? Ja, nein, vielleicht und warum? Und da konnte man am Beispiel Hamburg als Hacker immer mit dem Vorteil arbeiten. Man hat dann irgendwie diese Technik. Man kann sie auch auseinandernehmen, man kann sie im Hacker umsetzen.
Okay, also es gab so einen Wahlstift. Was hat der genau gemacht und wie ist er kaputt gemacht worden?
Dieser Wahlstift in Hamburg war ein kugelschreiberähnliches Gerät mit einer Sensorik in der Stiftspitze. Und die zeichnete auf, wenn man auf dem Papier ein Kreuz machte. Das heißt, man erhoffte sich, dass man eben mit diesem traditionellen Papierwählen sehr ähnlich im Verfahren elektronisch zählen kann, indem man einfach die Sensorik nutzte und ein speziell präpariertes Papier, was man dazu brauchte.
Also ich mache tatsächlich noch mal ein Kreuz, aber das Ergebnis wird elektronisch ausgelesen.
Richtig, das war für Hamburg auch relativ wichtig, denn Hamburg hat kein Wahlzettel, sondern ein Wahlbuch. Das heißt, das ist ein relativ kompliziertes Wahlverfahren.
Das haben wir übrigens mehr Demokratie zu verdanken. Die haben das Personenwahlrecht in Hamburg eingeführt.
Die waren tatsächlich erfolgreich. Und da war es natürlich so, dass wir als Hacker immer den Vorteil haben, wir haben die Technik, wir können uns die ansehen. Und die Schwachstellen entdecken. Und dann kann man natürlich auch sehr viel leichter mit den Medien arbeiten, weil die natürlich diese Skandalisierung mögen. Das ist klar. So ähnlich ist es letztlich mit dem Staatstrojaner im Oktober letzten Jahres auch gelaufen. Man hat dann die Technik, man kann die auseinandernehmen, man kann die Schwachstellen auch benennen, ganz klar. Man kann die Rechtsbrüche anhand der Technik klar machen. So war das natürlich für den Hacker dann auch ein Fest.
Aber wie war es denn bei dem Wahlschiff? Was ist denn da genau? Was habt ihr da nachgewiesen? Und wie ist dann vor allen Dingen die Reaktion auch gewesen?
Zunächst mal gab es da auch mit Hamburg Gespräche. Da war tatsächlich ganz am Anfang, als die Idee aufkam, war schon die Überlegung da, hey, wollen wir mit denen konstruktiv zusammenarbeiten? Also es gab mal so ein Beirat, so einen technischen, wollen wir da reingehen? Aber da war schnell klar, dass wir das deshalb nicht machen können, weil keinerlei Transparenz gegeben war. Das heißt, der ganze Prozess sollte unter der Decke bleiben. Alle Erkenntnisse, die wir da hätten über die Technik gewinnen können, die wären halt so einer sogenannten NDA zum Opfer gefallen. Wir hätten da unterschreiben müssen, dass wir da öffentlich nichts darüber sagen. Das war für uns natürlich, ja, machen wir nicht Kriterium. Das glaube ich für den Club auch bei allen technischen Projekten. Und dann war natürlich so, dass die nächste Jagd war, wir brauchen diese Technik in die Hand. Ist ja auch immer nicht so einfach. Und da war auch übrigens über Informationsfreiheitsgesetz nichts zu erlangen, denn da spielen ja immer Geschäftsgeheimnisse der lieferenden Firmenrolle. Das wäre ja jetzt in Hamburg eventuell ein bisschen anders.
Das wäre jetzt einfacher, ja.
Genau, war aber damals nicht. Das heißt, wir mussten uns erstmal so ein Ding besorgen. War schon nicht so einfach, denn die Firma hat da immer wieder Modifikationen vorgenommen an der Technik auch. Also immer dann, wenn wir da wieder Sicherheitslücken aufgedeckt hatten. Wir hatten auch Informationsveranstaltungen damals. Also wir haben da so eine Strategie gefahren, die teilweise zusammenarbeitet, aber dann letztlich war uns wichtig, wie wir das hacken können. Also einmal über den Rechner, wo diese Wahlstifte dann ja auch eingesteckt werden mussten. Die Technik haben wir uns näher angesehen, aber letztlich haben wir den eigentlichen Hack über Papier gemacht. Und das Papier hatte die Programmierung. Das war nämlich prepariert mit kaum sichtbaren Microdots, also ganz kleine Punkte, die eigentliche Programmierung des Systems darstellen. Und so haben wir dann noch angesetzt, indem wir einfach Papier manipuliert haben, um es um zu programmieren.
Also der Stift hat im Prinzip eine Mini-Kamera und guckt, an welcher Stelle des Papiers ihr das Kreuz macht. Und das lässt sich halt leicht austauschen.
Genau, das haben wir auch getan, indem wir das Papier, das Wahrheitszeitlicht manipuliert haben.
Das sieht aus, als ob ich Partei B wähle, aber in Wirklichkeit das Papier ist von Partei A drunter.
Du machst das Kreuz bei Partei B, aber vorher hat man halt das Feld, wo das Kreuz hinkommt, ausgetauscht gegen das von Partei A.
Das ist nicht wirklich sichtbar, weil die Punkte sind ganz klein.
Also grundlegend kaputt kann man auch relativ leicht manipulieren.
Es gab bei diesem Wahrstoff noch andere Hacks, die wir natürlich überlegt haben. Der simpelste Hack ist natürlich, du sagst, in Hamburg bringt ihr eure eigenen Stifte mit. Dann gibt es ein Problem für die Wahlorganisation.
Oder die lustige Idee, bringt doch einfach einen Edding mit und malt einen kleinen Punkt auf die Linse, wenn ihr morgens die ersten im Wahlwahl seid.
Da waren viele Angriffspunkte, aber letztlich haben wir uns natürlich auch darüber geärgert, dass die Stadt da viel Geld verloren hat. Denn ein Teil der Technik war schon gekauft worden und das Geld war verloren. Das waren über 5 Millionen Euro.
Was ich mir jetzt als die schwierige Stelle vorstelle, ist, man kommt immer an und sagt, wir haben das jetzt gehackt und man will ja eigentlich erreichen, wir benutzen das Teil nicht. Aber was ich mir vorstelle, ist, dass die sagen, das können wir doch reparieren.
Ist auch so, ist bis heute so. Ist es immer noch so? Ja, natürlich auch beim Staatsdrojaner. Bei all diesen Dingen oder bei der Biometrie, wenn man zeigen kann, wie leicht man Trappen bauen kann. Natürlich ist immer die Argumentation, das Problem fixen wir. Das kennen wir, aber wir finden das schon immer heitern, weil das doch immer dieselben Argumentationsmuster sind.
Wobei, also ich glaube, der Wahlstift ist in Hamburg nachhaltig vom Tisch. Also wenn ich das Wort da im Rathaus erwähne, dann werden die alle ganz blass.
Es gab einen juristischen Unangenehm mit Nachspiel. Wir haben über mehrere Instanzen gegen den Hersteller prozessieren müssen. Weil? Ja, der hat uns das Wort verbieten wollen. Das war also ein Meinungsäußerungsdelikt, wie man so schön sagt. Sie wollten also, dass Teile unserer Pressemitteilung zurückgenommen werden und nicht weiter veröffentlicht werden. Da mussten wir über zwei Instanzen gehen. Das ist natürlich für den CCC auch immer ein hoher finanzielles Risiko. Und natürlich auch viel Arbeit. Also, muss man mal sagen, wir sind ja generell bei Gerichten zugange. Beim Verfassungsgericht ist es natürlich so, dass die Arbeit, die man da reinsteckt, ist niemals umsonst. Die hat natürlich eine große Wirkung, aber es gibt ja darunter auch noch Arbeit. Einmal dann, wenn der CCC selbst prozessiert, oder eben weil er vor allen Dingen angezeigt wird, aber auch, wenn man mal als Gutachter tätig ist und auch das kommt vor. Das macht teilweise viel Arbeit, kann aber auch wichtig sein, weil sich dadurch nicht die Gesetzgebung, sondern die Rechtssetzung ändert. Nämlich durch bestimmte Gerichtsverfahren. Also es ist tatsächlich, man hat mit den Juristen öfter zu tun, als man vielleicht sie möchte.
Ist aber auch sozusagen im Prinzip eine Art von Politik, also eine Art von ihr ändert unseren Lebensumraum.
Bei dem Wahlstift war es klar, dass es auch eine Medienkampagne war. Also wir müssen dann mit dem wollen und müssen mit den Medien arbeiten, um das Thema überhaupt in der Bevölkerung interessant zu machen. Dass es also hier Schwächen an den Systemen gibt. Das war aber schon immer eine Strategie des CCC von Anfang an, mit den Medien und der Öffentlichkeit zu arbeiten. Andere Chancen haben wir ja nicht. Nicht wahr? Wir sitzen ja gerade in den Medien.
Sehr schön macht ihr das. Wunderbar.
Also man muss auch mal sehen, so eine Projekte wie in Hamburg oder auch beim Wahlstift oder auch bei der Vorwärtsentsprechung, wo dann ja auch ein Urteil kam, natürlich motiviert das für andere Themen, wo es nicht so gut läuft und wo man dauernd Klatschen kriegt und wo eben andere Mehrheiten im Parlament sind, die einen überstimmen oder eine andere Meinung haben. Das motiviert dann wieder, wenn man mal eine Schlacht gewinnt. Das ist schon wichtig.
Das wollte ich gerade noch fragen. Wir leben ja tatsächlich in einer Demokratie, also zumindest ansatzweise, möglicherweise. Und jetzt habt ihr ja sozusagen so Themenvorschläge. Wir machen konstruktive Gesetzesvorschläge, die werden auch umgesetzt. Es gibt eine Technologie, die ist aber grundsätzlich kaputt, und das können wir euch auch zeigen. Und dann gibt es ja möglicherweise in der Mitte noch so Sachen, wo ihr sagt, es gibt hier ein Thema, und aus politischen Überlegungen sind wir dafür, dass es so und so läuft. Und dann sagt die Mehrheit aber so, nee, wir stimmen das anders ab. Kann man sich dann trotzdem damit zufrieden geben?
Naja, das ist die typische Kompromissfrage. Die hatten wir ja beim Transparenzgesetz ein bisschen abgeschwächter Form auch schon. Natürlich sind es manchmal Kräuten, die wir schlucken. Und es gibt eigentlich oft im CCC eine ganz klare Meinung, wo diese rote Linie ist, also wo kein Kompromiss mehr geht. Oder wo es sich nicht lohnt, weil es grundsätzlich falsch ist. Aber das ist natürlich von Thema zu Thema sehr unterschiedlich. Also ich würde mal sagen, manchmal braucht es auch ein bisschen Zeit, dass man eine Kompromisslinie finden könnte. Also bei Open-Data-Projekten gibt es da manchmal durchaus so eine Fragestellung. Also etwa bei klassischen Fragen wie, was ist denn öffentlicher als Datum und was ist ein privates Datum? Da kann manchmal ein Graubereich sein, da muss man sich auch mal einigen.
Ich habe da ein schönes Beispiel. Zum Beispiel hatten wir ja in dem Gesetz auch die Baugenehmigungen drin. Jetzt hast du aber das Problem, dass nach aktueller Rechtsprechung die Flurstücknummer, also jedes Grundstück in diesem Land hat eine eigene Nummer, die ist aber eigentlich nach Rechtsprechung ein personenbezogenes Datum. Jetzt bringt mir aber, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel, ich wohne neben einer riesigen Brachfläche und da soll jetzt neu entwickelt werden, da ist irgendein schwieriger Investor am Start, der macht nur Luxuswohnungen mit Karloft und so weiter. Und ohne die Flurstück-Nummer kann ich ja nie rausfinden, was da passieren wird. Und wenn es da einen Bauantrag gibt und so weiter. Und das sind halt so Sachen, wo dann immer wieder auch drüber nachgedacht wird, wo drüber gerungen wird. Findet man das gut? Eigentlich als Datenschützer findet man das gut, dass das geschützt ist. Andererseits aus sozialer Sicht braucht man das Datum vielleicht. Und daher gibt es da immer wieder Rangeleien und Diskussionen drüber.
Also politische Arbeit auch für Hacker bedeutet irgendwann auch Kompromissbereitschaft?
Naja, aber vielleicht in einem etwas begrenzteren Rahmen.
Aber überhaupt.
Man kann natürlich radikaler auftreten, als das viele Politiker können, weil sie einfach an ihren Parteikonsens gebunden sind.
Das ist klar zu sagen. Aber letztendlich muss man, wenn man politisch arbeiten will. Wir beschäftigen uns gleich noch mit dem, also ich vermute das zumindest als anstrengendsten Aspekt der politischen Arbeit, das ist die Mitarbeit in der sogenannten Enquete-Kommission für Internet und digitale Gesellschaft. Bevor das losgeht, machen wir noch das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Blue Moon of Ritz, heute das Chaos Radio, wo Constanze Kurz und Dodger vom Chaos Computer Club zu Gast sind, beziehungsweise das Studio übernommen haben. Hallo und willkommen zurück.
Wir haben das Studio nicht übernommen.
Na komm, ihr sagt hier schon jetzt zwei Stunden lang, was gerade so geht.
Du hast auch mal was gesagt.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Zum Beispiel darf ich am Anfang einer halben Stunde mal sagen, wir reden heute darüber, wie Hacker Politik machen. Wir hatten schon ein sehr positives Beispiel, nämlich in Hamburg das Transparenzgesetz, wo nicht nur Hacker überlegt haben, wir machen jetzt mal Politik, sondern wo das auch noch geklappt hat und das Gesetz durchgegangen ist.
In schnellster Zeit.
In schnellster Zeit, wo jetzt also der Staat in Zukunft sagen muss, wenn er irgendwelche Entscheidungen trifft, muss er die öffentlich verfügbar machen, so dass man die sich einfach runterladen und maschinell auslesen kann. Wir haben auch schon ein bisschen gesprochen über Projekte, die auch konstruktiv sind, aber nicht so schnell vonstatten gehen und auch darüber, dass der Club der Ansicht ist. Manchmal Dinge auch einfach kaputt machen muss, um zu zeigen, dass bestimmte Technologien nicht gehen. Jetzt gibt es eine Sache, wo auch eine Vertreterin im Club dabei ist, die ich mir persönlich sehr anstrengend vorstelle, von dem, was ich außen davon wahrnehme. Und das ist die Mitarbeit in der sogenannten Enquete-Kommission für Internet und Digitale Gesellschaft. Und da sitzt auch Constanze Kurz mit drin, die im Studio ist. Kannst du noch mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen für Leute, die das noch nie gehört haben, was das eigentlich ist?
Also eine Enquete-Kommission ist im Bundestag eine Art Untersuchungsausschuss und soll den zukünftigen Gesetzgeber beraten. Da hast du dann keine konkreten Gesetze gemacht, sondern man guckt sich an, wie sollten zukünftige Gesetzgeber in den später gefassten Beschlüssen, vielleicht technische Entwicklungen, die sich ergeben, mitbedenken. Man macht Vorschläge, also ist die Idee und das Ergebnis dieser Enquete-Kommission ist im Wesentlichen ein recht langer Bericht. Der Grund dafür ist, dass in diesem Einsetzungsbeschluss, der von den Parteien des Bundeswerks beschlossen wurde, sehr viele Themen drin sind. Das heißt, alles, was mit Netzpolitik und Internet zu tun hat, im allerweitesten Sinne wurde in diese inhaltliche Liste aufgenommen. Und wir werden da also einen sehr umfangreichen Bericht am Ende abgeben.
Wie kommt man denn überhaupt dazu, da mitzuarbeiten? Also wie ist das vonstattengegangen?
Für den Club war es so, dass uns alle Parteien des Bundestages angesprochen haben, als klar war, dass es diese Enquete-Kommission irgendwann geben würde.
Deshalb haben wir gerade vergessen, die besetzte Hälfte Politiker und andere Hälfte Experten, die die Parteien benannt haben.
Es sind 17 Abgeordnete des Bundestages, und zwar paritätisch, also so, wie die Parteien gewählt wurden. Und 17 Sachverständige, die jeweils von der Fraktion benannt werden. Die Abgeordneten haben einen Vertreter noch, also wenn sie mal nicht können, dann haben sie einen Stellvertreter, die die Sachverständigen nicht. Und es gibt den sogenannten 18 Sachverständigen, das ist die Öffentlichkeit. Die sollte sozusagen mitarbeiten. Das hat aber doch insgesamt nicht gut funktioniert für die meisten Projektgruppen. Es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen. Aber zumindest arbeiten wir auch noch daran, die jetzt neu eingesetzten letzten Projektgruppen wieder mehr der Öffentlichkeit zuzuwenden. Es ist nicht so einfach, wie sich das vielleicht viele gewünscht hatten.
Aber nochmal zurück zum Anfang. Da stand fest, diese Kommission soll besetzt werden. Und alle Parteien aachten sich, hey, wir wären bestimmt total cool, wenn jemand beim CCC von uns mitarbeitet.
Wir wissen nicht genau, wie die Parteien im Einzelnen den CCC sehen. Es gab Gespräche, das sind tatsächlich so eine... Also die CDU hatte zum Beispiel Kambinengespräche. Das sind wirklich so Hintergrundgespräche. Man versucht auszuloten, was stellen die sich vor, was stellen wir uns vor und geht die irgendwie zusammen. Tja, und dann haben wir die Gespräche geführt. Es war auch noch nicht klar, wer vom CCC denn machen würde. Wobei natürlich die ganzen Mehrleute vom CCC gesagt haben, nee, auf gar keinen Fall, mach ich nicht.
Warum? Also grundsätzlich, das ist so politikergedönst oder eher, weil das zu viel Arbeit ist?
Ich glaube, weil am Anfang ein bisschen umstritten war, ob das viel Sinn ergibt, ob da wirklich was bei rauskommt. Also es war von Anfang an nicht so ganz klar, was soll das eigentlich.
Also das ist halt nicht ein Gesetzvorschlag, sondern es ist der Vorschlag für eine Richtung, in die ein Gesetzvorschlag mal gehen könnte.
Man macht halt ein bisschen Ausblick in die Zukunft. Man versucht den zukünftigen Gesetzgeber ja auch zu beraten. Und das war nicht allen gegeben. Man glaubt, man muss schon auch ein bisschen... Leidensfähig. Jetzt sagst du jetzt im Nachhinein, mir war auch am Anfang nicht klar, wie viel Arbeit ist das. Was ist das für ein Prozedere? Wie würde Klima dort sein? Das wusste man ja vorher nicht. Das ist richtig. Wie ist das gekommen? Wir haben uns angehört, die Parteien sich vorstellen und versucht unideologisch ranzugehen. Wir hatten damals mit der Linksfraktion überhaupt keine Kontakte. Also wir kannten eigentlich nur einen Abgeordneten näher, mit dem wir mal zu tun hatten, wegen kleinerer parlamentarischer Anfragen, die wir mit mehreren Parteien öfter mal zusammen machen. Aber nachdem wir mit ihnen gesprochen haben, war schnell klar, die wollen was von uns im Sinne von wirklich Gespräch suchen. Die wollen uns nicht beeinflussen. Das heißt, es ist vollkommen klar, dass wir da immer unsere Meinung vertreten können und da auch nicht irgendwie mit denen ins Gehaar gekommen. Dann haben wir das so gemacht. Und ich habe es eigentlich auch nicht bereut, denn die beiden Abgeordneten sind ja bloß zwei mit denjenigen, die ich arbeite. Es sind Halina Wafsiniak und Petra Sitte, das sind übrigens auch zwei Frauen, was ich sehr schön finde, weil diese gesamte Unionsfraktion besteht immer aus Männern und die FDP auch. Und unsere Seite, wo die Linken sitzen, sind die Grünen und die SPD, das ist auch so aufgeteilt. Die sind dann immer so bunt und mehr Frauen als Männer. Das ist lustig. Naja, ich muss sagen, beide Parlamentarier, das ist für mich auch ein Lernprozess gewesen, sind für mich in vieler Hinsicht Vorbilder. Also sind beide sehr bürgernahe Parlamentarier, mit auch richtig Herzblut, mit Politik, aber sie sind natürlich auch als Mitglieder der Linkspartei immer so ein bisschen, ja, die Bubenmänner, mit denen arbeitet niemand gern zusammen. Die Linke ist ja nach wie vor im Bundestag auch relativ weit außen, mit denen reden sie alle nicht so gern, aber sie sind für mich in vieler Hinsicht so richtig Vorbild-Politiker. Ich bin erstaunt gewesen, weil es natürlich verschiedene Typen von Abgeordneten gibt. Für mich ist das ja auch ein interessanter sozialer Einblick in dieses Raumschiff da.
Also auch mit einer Partei zusammengearbeitet, die möglicherweise man vorher gar nicht so viel Schirm hatte bei dem Thema.
Die hatte keine Ausform und die Netzpolitik, das war alle noch ein bisschen im Fluss und ist natürlich auch innerhalb dieser Partei oft umstritten. Es ist ja nicht so, dass sie sich immer alleine sind.
Und du kannst aber letztendlich sagen, bist du da als Vertreterin des Clubs und bist sozusagen der Partei da auch keine Rechenschaft. Aber wie muss man sich das jetzt?
Na ja, man musste das oft anmerken. Und ketten mussten wir uns als Sachverständige, ich hab das auch sehr häufig selbst getan, abgrenzen von den Parteien. Also ich hab immer wieder darauf bestanden, dass sie mich nicht einsortieren in die Linkspartei, sondern dass ich Sachverständige bin. Das betone ich manchmal bis heute. Also das haben nicht viele andere der Sachverständigen gemacht. Und wir haben da Sachverständigen gern immer mit ihrer Fraktion gestimmt. Also wir haben da richtig Stimmenvieh, die einfach nie abweichend gestimmt haben, was mich natürlich bestört. Weil ich mich auf so eine Parteilinie als Sachverständige nie eingelassen hätte.
Jetzt ist es ja so, das klingt alles nach hoher Politik, auch wenn es nicht direkt im Gesetz ist. Kannst du uns mal ganz anschaulich erzählen, wie ist denn, wie funktioniert denn so eine Sitzung? Also was genau machst du denn da? Und vor allen Dingen, wie gehen die Leute in so einem Ding miteinander um?
Also die Arbeit besteht ja einmal aus den Kommissionssitzungen. Da kommen alle zusammen, die teilweise auch von weit an reisen. Da nehmen nicht nur Abgeordnete, sondern auch die Sachverständigen. Aber die wesentliche Arbeit passiert in den sogenannten Projektgruppen. Da sind also thematisch die Themen aufgeteilt. Und dann teilt man auch die Abgeordneten und Sachverständigen auf, je nach ihren Interessen. Dann man ja nicht in der großen Kommissionssammenarbeit, sondern sich dann immer so acht oder zehn oder zwölf Leute aktiv beteiligen an dieser Projektarbeit. Und nach längerem Hickhack war klar, dass diese Projektgruppensitzungen ganz zum großen Teil nicht öffentlich sind. Und dann geht es natürlich auch anders ab als in der Umkehrkommission in der Großen Runde. Denn die ist ja gefilmt, die gibt es als Stream auf Bundestags.de. Und da ist immer viel Scharfwächs da reden und so. Und da ist vor allen Dingen auch sehr viele Geschäftsordnungstricks.
Was ist denn ein Geschäftsordnungstrick?
Das ist zum Beispiel, naja, die Union ist zum Beispiel einmal nicht erschienen. Die Unionsfraktion, die FDP, das ist die Enquete-Kommission war einberufen. Und die sind aber nicht erschienen zum Beginn. Dann haben wir natürlich den stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden, der ja schon zugegen war von der SPD damals, der Herr Dörrmann, der ist mittlerweile nicht mehr dabei. Da haben wir ihm gesagt, na ja, dann machen wir eben unsere Enquete-Kommission so. Aber das sind dann so Tricks, dann kommen die einfach nicht. Oder sie haben Abstimmungen verschoben über Geschäftsordnungstricks. Da war mir vorher nicht klar, dass die so eine Spiele spielen. Ich habe früher wahrscheinlich mal den naiv und doof war. Ich habe das für sachlicher gehalten, aber oft ist es eben, ja, das ist eine rituelle Partei, taktischer Art oft.
Das hat sich bis nach Kindergarten an.
Ja, manchmal ist es wie Kindergarten, also mehrere Sachverständige waren ein paar Mal drauf und dran, da auch zu gehen. Also vor allen Dingen einen Tag, wo sie uns da haben sitzen lassen und einfach nicht kamen.
Also was passiert dann, da kann die Sitzung nicht stattfinden, weil die nur stattfinden kann, wenn so viele Leute da sind?
Man hätte stattfinden können, aber der stellvertretende Vorsitzende hat sie ja nicht eröffnet und der Vorsitzende gehört ja zur CDU und da kamen nicht.
Warum geht man da nicht einfach?
Wir haben uns tatsächlich ein paar Mal überlegt, da gab es ein paar Sachverständige, die das überlegt haben. Aber dann, also letztlich, also zumindest für mich war dann die Überlegung zum einen, also mir waren manche Themen sind mir sehr wichtig. Man nannt da eine Menge darüber, also wer welche Positionen hat. Ich denke, man kann da auch einen Teil der Überzeugungsarbeit leisten. Also teilweise sind die Berichte, die jetzt geschrieben wurden, schon relativ, aus meiner Sicht, ziemlich modern und zukunftsträchtig. Man versucht halt im Konsens zu arbeiten. Wer mich manchmal am Montagsabend nach dem Bundestag trifft, ist ja meistens montags, der merkt dann immer schon mal eine schlechte Laune. Aber es gibt eben auch mal gute Momente, wo man sie zum Beispiel mal überzeugen konnte, wenn man Punkte in die Berichte bekommen hat, von denen man es nicht erwartet hat. Ja, es hat halt so negative Schattenseiten. Im Club wurde teilweise auch belächelt einfach, weil durch diese parteitaktischen Scharmmütze, glaube ich, die Enquete insgesamt jetzt einen schlechten Ruf hat. Aber aus meiner Sicht hat sich trotzdem gelohnt, wenn es viel Arbeit ist.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ob man das nicht möglich ist als verschwendete Lebenszeit. Also auf der einen Seite hast du Transparenz gesetzt in Hamburg, haben halt was bewegt, ja, und dann hast du diese Kommission, die dann was entscheidet für eine Regierung, die es gar nicht noch gibt und das dann...
Also jetzt im Nachhinein, ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig mit dem Präsumieren, weil die Arbeit läuft ja noch. Also vielleicht würde ich es auch anders sehen, wenn die Enquete-Kommission ihre Arbeit abgestaßen hat. Ich würde es niemandem raten zu tun, muss ich offen sagen. Und ich könnte auch begründen, wieso, aber ich glaube tatsächlich, dass die Wirkung und die Arbeit, also das ist tatsächlich auch viel Schreibarbeit, die da reingeht, auch Zeit, das lohnt sich nicht für den Output. Andererseits ist es mir so wichtig, dass es, wenn sich nicht noch schlimmere Geschäftsordnung, Tricks und Trollereien der Parteien da zugesellen.
Wenn jetzt jemand vom Neuartigen Rundfunk empfangen wird, will ich auch mitmachen, wie fängt man es am besten an?
Für mich gibt es ein paar Grundsätze. Einen davon habe ich von dem von mir sehr verehrten Norm Schomsky. Norm Schomsky ist ein amerikanischer Intellektueller, der eigentlich ein Philosoph ist, der sich Gedanken macht über die Gesellschaft. Und er hat in einem Buch, und er sagte doch oft in Interviews, mal analysiert, warum wir in den westlichen Demokratien, wo wir uns gut beteiligen können, wir haben in den Parteien, in denen wir mitwirken können, wir haben vergleichsweise eine starke demokratische Mitwirkung, wir haben Transparenz, warum gerade in diesen Gesellschaften viele so diese Agonie haben und glauben, sie können nichts ändern und Politik oder Parteien verdrossen sind. Und für mich ist wichtig, dass ich die Möglichkeiten, die ich besitze, nutze. Und die sind so vielfältig, man hält es kaum aus. Man kann sich eindringen in den NGOs, von denen in Deutschland viele gibt, die auch teilweise viele Erfolge verzeichnen können. Man kann sich natürlich in den Parteien selbst bereit machen, wenn man zu diesem Typ Mensch gehört.
Sind das denn tatsächlich, im Umgang mit Politikern, die ihr beide gehabt habt, sind Politiker andere Menschen?
Sag du mal für Hamburg, da ist es ja nochmal anders im Land.
Also ich glaube halt, die Politik verändert die Menschen. Weil in dem Moment, wo du in diesem Spiel bist, musst du dich den Regeln unterwerfen. Du fängst halt dann wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann an, irgendwelche Winkelzüge, Geschäftsordnungstricks und so weiter zu probieren oder auswendig zu lernen, musst dich Regeln unterwerfen, was jemand anders nicht machen würde. Aber gerade in Hamburg habe ich einfach die Erfahrung gemacht, bestes Beispiel war einer der Leute, die auf der SPD-Seite mit uns verhandelt haben, oder zwei von denen, waren nach der Bürgerschaftssitzung, wo das Gesetz beschlossen wurde, mit uns, mit den Bündnissen Bier trinken. Die waren auch auf der Grillparty, die wir eine Woche später gemacht haben, weil die es einfach cool fanden, mit uns das durchgekämpft zu haben. Und das heißt aber, das ist nicht der Archetypus oder der prototypische Politiker, sondern die sind einfach dichter an den Leuten dran. Aber ich glaube, Politik verändert die Leute, klar.
Ich denke, im Bund merkt man das noch mehr. Ich beobachte in den Projektgruppensitzungen oft eine wirklich sachliche, konstruktive Arbeit. Das ist auch oft angenehm oder auch einen gewissen Lärm willen. Für einige der Politiker dort waren viele Themen, gerade wenn es sehr technisch wird, noch unbekannt oder sie wussten wenig darüber. Aber es gibt natürlich da auch Politiker, die da drinsetzen, muss ich ganz offen sagen, die hören nie zu. Die haben sich nie wirklich sinnvoll beteiligt. Das gibt es da auch. Man muss natürlich schon sagen, dass es doch einen Unterschied macht, ob man eher so ein Hinterbänkler ist und sich bestimmten Themen zuwendet, also jetzt nicht so sehr stark in der medialen Öffentlichkeit steht, oder ob man schon eine Menge zu sagen hat in einer Fraktion und ändert. Der Machtfaktor ist nicht zu unterschätzen. Generell gilt für die Landesparlamente, dass es eine angenehmer Atmosphäre ist. Ich habe das ja auch in anderen Landesparlamenten schon erlebt. Im Bund ist es schon ruppiger, natürlich.
Okay, also einsteigen ihr auf Landesebene für Anfänger?
Ich denke, man muss sich sein Pläsier suchen. Und zwar sollte man sich das Pläsier danach suchen, zuerst mal was einen innerlich interessiert. Ich denke, das Wichtigste ist, wenn man wirklich ein bisschen mit der Politik arbeiten will, dass man Kompetenz hat. Denn sich das sachlich anzueignen, ist erstmal schon die beste Grundlage. Dann kommt man viel besser ans Gespräch. Und dann sollte man aus meiner Sicht nur die Wege suchen, die man selber will. Wenn man will, kann man sich ja heute in vielen Parteien engagieren. Neue alte etablierte Jugendorganisationen, lalalala, all das da. Oder eben die NGOs. Natürlich im Club kann man es genauso machen. Man kann sich seine Ecke suchen. Aber wir haben heute auch das Netz. Das heißt, man kann seine eigene Öffentlichkeit schaffen. Also ich glaube, die Möglichkeiten waren nie besser. Und ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, warum letztlich jetzt so viele neue Sachen kommen, die konstruktiv sind. Ich denke, das ist ein Trend, der sich fortsetzen wird. Es wird mehr davon kommen. Und die Politik kann und wird sich dem nicht mehr verschließen können. Und das ist eine Chance für uns. Wir müssen die ergreifen.
Also was ich ganz kurz für mich persönlich daraus gezogen habe aus der ganzen Nummer ist, ich will keine Parteipolitik machen. Ich mache lieber außerparlamentarisch das Thema, das mich gerade bewegt und das Thema, wo ich sage, da bin ich dick drin und da will ich jetzt was bewegen und mache von Außen Druck.
Das geht mir ganz genauso.
Na weil diese ganzen Parteien-Hierarchien, ich muss mich erst mal da durchkämpfen, ich muss durch die ganzen Instanzen durch, bis mir dann irgendjemand mal zuhört und so weiter. Sobald dieser ganze Parteien-Overhead, der da dranhängt, das ist nichts für mich.
Es ist auch ein gewisser Luxus, den wir haben. Also das betrifft Dodger und mich glaube ich in selber Weise. Also zunächst mal vertreten wir Positionen hinter denen wir originär immer stehen. Also das geht für mich als Club-Sprecherin aber sowieso. Also ich würde nie was vertreten, also dann rede ich halt nicht drüber, wenn ich den Konsens im Club nicht teile. Ich kann einfach wirklich meine sachlich begründete Meinung vertreten und muss mich nicht irgendwelchen Parteiflügen beschlüssen. Das empfinde ich als Luxus, weil diese Unabhängigkeit würde ich mir immer wahren wollen.
Brauchen wir trotzdem Parteiarbeit?
Ja natürlich. Parteien sind...
Also wer das will, bitte machen.
Ja klar. Parteien sind schon... Es wurde immer viel gemeckert über Parteien. Auch schon bevor die Piratenpartei aufkam. Also letztlich erfüllt die eine wichtige Funktion. Deswegen haben wir das Parteiengesetz und deswegen ist es ja auch so grundgesetzlich festgelegt. Sie sind nur aus meiner Sicht in manchen ihren Funktionalitäten total verharzt und irgendwie festgefahren. Aber auch das ändert sich gerade. Also ich finde da ist auch viel im Fluss.
Die sollen sogar twittern jetzt manche von denen.
Hast du das schon mal gesehen?
Na, in so einer Kamera dabei, Bundestag.de, da kann man das manchmal sehen.
Heißt das Olive-Kahn ist Politiker? Naja, egal. Noch eine ganz persönliche Frage an beide von euch. Was ist das nächste Projekt, das ihr angehen wollt?
Dodger? Das fängt an.
Oh ja, ich habe da ein total gutes, ich war morgen früh auf Diffusion.
Komm, wir dürfen Werbung für Diffusion machen, oder? Aber ist das ein politisches Projekt eigentlich?
Man kann ja eh keine Werbung dafür machen, weil es ja eh immer ausverkocht ist.
Ne, ich muss gestehen, wir haben ja jetzt in Hamburg noch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, dieses Informationsregister zu konzipieren und umzusetzen, weil das haben wir gar nicht erwähnt. Das dauert noch zwei Jahre. Die Zeit haben sie dafür. Und wir haben uns in den Verhandlungen explizit ausgebeten und reinschreiben lassen, dass wir die beraten dürfen bei der Umsetzung des Ganzen, damit das nicht hinterher so ein Multimillionen-Dollar-Grab wird.
Also Umsetzung heißt jetzt nicht mehr das Gesetz, sozusagen.
Wir programmieren nicht die Webseite dafür für dieses Informationsregister.
Aber ihr habt ein Auge drauf.
Wir haben ein Auge drauf, was sie da treiben und wie das dann später gemacht wird. Und das wird uns noch mindestens anderthalb bis zwei Jahre beschäftigen. Ja, ich hab zu tun.
Gibt es denn sonst noch ein Thema, wo du vorschlagen würdest? Da sollte man sich mal drum kümmern.
Na ja gut, wo immer Leute gebraucht werden, sind natürlich alle aktuellen Themen.
Na genau, und da dein Lieblingsthema.
Ja, im Moment treibt mich Leistungsschutzrecht ziemlich um. Also das macht mich so ein bisschen rasend.
Okay, ich überlege gerade, kriegen wir es jetzt kurz zusammengefasst? Nein, ich möchte dann an dieser Stelle die Gelegenheit für Werbung für mich machen. Bei Trackback haben wir in den letzten beiden Sendungen versucht, zu klären, was das Leistungsschutzrecht ist und womöglich keine gute Idee ist, dass man es im Internet nicht mehr verlinken darf.
Ich würde das ja anders zusammenfassen.
Bitte?
Na ja, der Punkt ist doch, wenn sie diesen Gesetzentwurf durchbringen, haben wir ja schon gewonnen. Und wenn sie ihn aufgeben müssen, haben wir auch gewonnen.
Könntest du bitte so eine Diskussion nicht sechs vor zwölf anfangen?
Entschuldigung, aber ich finde, da können wir nur gewinnen, oder? Das ist doch super.
Das können wir vielleicht an anderer Stelle noch mal genauer ausdiskutieren. Was ist dein Projekt, dein nächstes?
Also die, die wir jetzt aufgezählt haben, werden mich natürlich, klar, ich habe traditionell immer relativ viele Projekte, aber derzeit, also für die Sommerkampagne, finde ich es sehr attraktiv, diesen Gesetzentwurf zur Störerhaftung mit einzelnen Parteien zu besprechen und euch der Kampagne zu bauen. Mal gucken, ich denke, das wird ein Clubprojekt hoffentlich noch werden. Also bisher ist es ja erst mal nur der Entwurf, der bei Netzpolitik Org zu finden ist, aber ich hoffe, dass man auch eine Kampagne daraus bauen kann. Aber die Themen wie die Vorurtszeitenspeicherung, ja oder also Akta natürlich, aber auch die Kulturwelt mag als Langpassprojekt werden und auch mich weiter beschäftigen. Also ich habe traditionell viele Baustellen, ich muss mal Dodger mal Recht geben, Leistungsschutzrecht wird in den nächsten Monaten auf jeden Fall auch ein Thema sein.
Naja, möglicherweise in einem Monat an dieser Stelle gibt es hier ein Chaosradio geben, mal gucken, worüber wir dann reden.
Das ist nicht ungewöhnlich, wenn man sagt, du hättest eben wieder das Leistungsschutzgeld vornehmen.
Recht, nicht Geld.
Denk nochmal nach, Dodger.
Leistungsschutzgeld. Na gut, das vielleicht beim nächsten Mal. Hier geht es erstmal, das war's mit dem Chaosradio. Vielen Dank, Dodger. Vielen Dank, Constanze. Für das Vorbeikommen und Erklären und Teilhaben lassen wir vor allen Dingen auch am Persönlichen erleben, wie Politik geht, wenn man sie auf einmal selber macht. Hier kommt jetzt Henrik Schröder mit dem Night Flight. Er wird euch Punk-Musik in die Ohren hineingeben. Und ich habe nur noch eine Nachricht für dich. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Macht immer schon eure Back-ups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.